the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club the third stop of the 2023 Grand
chest tour did not disappoint at the
super United rapid and Blitz in Zagreb
Croatia both veterans and newcomers
alike couldn't wait to show off their
rapid and Blitz prowess in the capital
city the lead changed early and often
with several early favorites jumping out
to impressive start but the main story
following day two was the slow start of
former world champion Magnus Carlson who
uncharacteristically suffered backtack
losses leaving the tournament wide open
but much to the Chagrin of hopeful Front
Runners Magnus quickly rebounded winning
two in a road to wrap up the rapid
section before advancing to the faster
time control it was in this
pressure-filled format that the ultimate
wild cart proved that once he is in form
he is simply Unstoppable blitzing out
win after win decimating the field to go
a historic nine out of nine to take
clear First Once Magnus took over the
lead he could not and would not be
caught sealing his victory as the 2023
super United rapid and Blitz Champion as
the European legs of the tour come to a
close sights are set on the capital of
Chess and America for the tour's fourth
and penultimate stop the St Louis rapid
and
Blitz
[Music]
the chess capital of the us we are here
in front of the St Louis Arch getting
ready for the St Louis rapid and Blitz
let's go back to the studio and get the
day
started welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America we proudly present the
St Louis rapid and Blitz the fourth stop
on the 2023 Grand chest store reaction
starts right
now hello and welcome everyone we're
live from our amazing studio in St Louis
bringing you some amazing chess action
I'm International Master Tanya sat
alongside me the one and only grandm
yasa San Tanya I'm so happy to have you
back in studio it's been years when was
it it was 2019 I was here last it's
amazing to be reunited with you here yes
incredible studio and some incredible
chess action coming up absolutely Tanya
welcome welcome hello everyone and
Welcome to our live action of the St
Louis Blitz and Rapid we are getting
ready for round one and my goodness when
I say we have the creme the La Creme of
the Chess World I really do mean it
Tanya please do the honor and tell us
the roster of participants let's take a
look at the players fighting it out in
St Louis in the rapid and Blitz and
we've got the defending champion from
2022 Grand chest alira fuja back in
Action also world number two the
reigning US champion Fabiano Carana the
two times World Championship Challenger
Yana pishi there's also going to be weso
who's had a shaky year but he looking at
finishing on a high absolutely as you
see we have these four Wild Card players
as well Liam Le Sam Sean Jeffrey Jean
Ray Robson and they are so anxious to
put their mark on this event and tell us
if you will about the grand chestor
standings let's take a look at where the
players stand going into the fourth leg
of the grand Chester leading the pack is
Fabiano Carana who did win the Super bat
classic in Romania the very first event
he's got 20 grand Chester points a lot
of money to boot I'm looking at the
prize money actually but go on tell us
more money talks yes and not just the
money but look at that he's only played
two events so the players have to play a
to of four Fab's got two more events
remaining he's already ahead of the pack
the players have to do a lot play their
best chess and one of them who has to do
that is ala fuja who is trailing Fabby
exactly and our defending Champion he
came into St Louis last year he wasn't
really a factor nobody had really
expected him to do much guess what he
won the St Louis rapid B he won the SFO
cup he became the tour champ champion
and as he said as a little boy it was
his dream to play in the event but tell
us about the format I take a look and we
do have a dream start with fuja facing
Fabby in the first round it is a 10
player round dropin which means it's
each plays each the players will have 25
minutes to start with and every time the
press to clock they get an additional 10
seconds we got three days of Rapid in
three games every day exactly and in the
blitz we have game five plus two and the
traditional uh scoring system for the
blitz two points for the rapid and I
love this no draw offers just take that
off your mind you're never going to
offer your opponent to draw because they
can't accept it either tell us about the
schedule I love it too yes uh you've got
to earn every each point here no draw
offers and this is the schedule coming
up it is 5 days of intense chess action
with three days of rapid and two days of
Fast and Furious Blitz to follow which
will be on day four and day five
outstanding and and we are very
fortunate to have in studio Peter
spitler grandm Peter Peter you look
great welcome welcome welcome to St
Louis I know you're not you don't me it
but I'll take it anyway uh hello
everyone and uh let's take a look at the
top three players uh in the grandchester
standings playing in the rapid and Blitz
event starting with Wesley so who is a
an absolute stalwart of the grand chest
tour who's won a couple of additions but
he's having a bit of a lackluster uh
tour so far so far you can see him in
fifth place there on 15.3 points
and uh the rapid and Blitz ratings very
very solid but he's capable of much more
when his on song uh following him in in
fourth place we have ala fua we've
already spoken a little bit about his uh
wonderful uh visit to St Louis last year
he's in fourth place in theour having
played two events 15.8 points uh there
he is on your screen and his rapid
rating is not what you would expect but
his blit rating is almost 2,900 and he
is deservedly sitting a top of the world
there and uh after him we have of course
the person on your screen there not
really uh ready to take his seat yet
there he is Fabiano Carana uh the
American number one although it's very
very tight these days who who is the
American number one yes uh but there
there you have an absolutely Stellar
performance in the tour so far clear
first on 20 points and way ah had
everybody in money earned uh 20 2765
rapid rating and he is famously a
completely useless Blitz player 20 2813
there on your screen fourth in the world
nobody really knows why he why he
bothers not not good at all it's very
well established that he can't play
Blitz and on that note we uh throw to
the final member of our commentary team
women woman Grand Master Anastasia
Carlovich who will be doing player
interviews and other very very important
things we can't do from
here hello Peter hello yaser hello Tanya
it's so great to see you but you are a
little bit far and the players are
closer so that's why I will be doing the
interviews with them here in this studio
I will also do the social media and I'm
really asking everyone to subscribe to
our social media accounts Grand chest
Tour St Louis chess club we are all
waiting for you in Instagram Facebook
and Twitter so let's have a look also to
the winners of the previous St Louis
rabbit and Blitz events let's remember
who were the winners so in 2017 it was
Leon aronian and then hikaro Nakamura
followed his steps look at this Leon won
it second time as well as Hikaru he won
it in 2021 there was a break in 2020
because of coid and in 20122 ALA fuja
made it four rounds to go he beat
everybody and won St Louis rapid and
Blitz will he be able to repeat his
success and win it for the second time
it's a good question and uh I'm really
excited to be here I'm looking forward
to the exciting event and let's go back
to the studio Anastasia it's wonderful
to have you you welcome welcome welcome
and well do the honors round one coming
up and we've already taken a peak we
know our Marquee match up tell us about
it Tanya the players are ready to go we
saw them in the playing Arena and this
is the action that's coming up it is the
All-American face off as Ray Robson
plays against Jeffrey Jong we've got
Liam Lee who is a last minute
replacement for ding Len exactly who
withdrew from the tournament uh we
haven't seen much of ding but we're
looking forward to him being back on the
board next year he will be playing a
Wesley so Sam savan takes on yanomi
Anish G against Maxim B we saw them have
a little bit of a pre game chat there
earlier so two friends facing each other
and the last one yes that is our Mari
matchup no question and a very special
moment as we have uh Susan pogar who was
inducted last night into the World Chess
Hall of Fame a very solemn ceremony that
was very nicely done thank you
Susan as we are ready ready round one
and again that Marquee match up
mouthwatering of uh of uh and ala Ali
Resa and before we get started let's do
it as quickly as possible Tanya who's
going to win oh are we doing predictions
eat quickly it's prediction time so the
St Louis Rafford and bl why do I have to
go first you're the lady you're ladies
first all right let's do this well I'm
going to pick Fabby for this one uh he's
won at the bronze medal of the world
rapid championship his speed chess has
been so on point this year US champion
he's just playing some of the best chess
it feels like the year of the Resurgence
of Fabby 2018 was his big year and 23 my
horse Faby in this one okay Peter jump
in I'm going to take Yan uh I think he
is very very focused he wants to do well
here yaser and I met him uh this morning
and he looked frankly
scary fit fit and scary and I think when
he's in that mood he is an incredibly
dangerous player very very very strong
player in Shor of time controls well wow
you guys are leaving the Fairway open
for me I'm going to go with the number
one ranked Blitz player in the field I
mean in the world uh come on fuja he's
he's he's going to repeat you heard it
here first andv is going to take Sam
Sean a wild card pick Sam as you
remember he did really well in the
Fisher random he was fantastic actually
in the fish would say like picking a
wild card is actually not such a bad
idea we saw in the first two events a
certain Wild Card called Magnus Carlson
win the events exactly and we're going
to jump right into it uh Peter we're
seeing a very very topical line of the
Berlin uh break it down first between
and Al this is the uh the game between
uh Fabiano and ala fua and Fabi starts
with uh E4 uh whoops that that went fast
that was not supposed to happen uh five
star with E4 and ala replies with a very
solid opening which has not been banned
in this tournament there has been some
events recently where it has been
basically forbidden to play this but uh
we're not at that stage yet uh in St
Louis regrettably uh so uh the D3 reply
to the Berlin not allowing the Queens to
disappear off the board by move nine
something that we welcome here in the
commentary Booth uh Bishop C5 by far the
main move here all of this is of course
very very wellestablished
Theory and I think the conclusion
current
uh is that uh black is doing fine but it
could become quite sharp in particular
if white decides to go for the lines
where the the white king goes uh goes
que side uh but hard to say by move six
there is uh you can either stop here or
continue talking 15 minutes I think I
should stop here no question but the
move H2 H3 for me is a little bit of a
surprise if you go back to the because
are you afraid of Bishop G4 Peter I mean
why would you play H3 I think you you're
just trying not to commit to a plan just
yet and you feel that this move will be
useful in most cases uh one thing I will
say is that with the black king still uh
in the center once you've played H3 as
he has uh if you now choose to Castle
King side for white it might actually
invite black to not Castle King side
themselves and black could try for
something like Rook G8 and then some
count to play with G7 G5 because because
the King on uh G1 with white providing a
hook uh for for this Pawn break uh could
maybe be a bit threatening not in this
particular position you still have to
wait for white to Castle King side but
it's a there's a lot of very fine
details here which are yet to be
clarified by our players exactly and I
also like how black isn't committing
aide to castalon could go Queen side yes
the options are open and it's Fabby who
goes into the first think in the
position after the last move exactly and
as we uh take our uh look around uh
we're going to go to the game of Anish
Gary and mvl now Anish is one of those
players
who I mean his potential is through the
roof I mean he in any single game I feel
like he can play Master Class chess and
yet at the same time he's one of those
players who doesn't lose he just doesn't
win often enough and I mean is that a
fair knock I mean he's a great player
there's nothing wrong with that I mean
but he's maybe too solid I think he's
one of the best in the world you hit the
nail on the head it's so hard to beat an
he's got this Universal style of play
but I think we underestimate his
ambition a little bit it's it's not the
solid boring approach I think he really
likes the correct chess he plays
principal chess he's always trying to
find the uh the best way forward in a
position and sometimes that might come
in the way of some practical uh
decision- making which offers chances to
win but also sometimes mess up the game
a little bit so with not having that not
taking that risk in those moments
sometimes the win or those chances seem
to slip out but I feel we've been seeing
Anish 2.0 this year we've been seeing
him play ambitious but it feels like a
different Anish he's fighting it out in
every game not as many draws and he did
get this repetition it was back in St
Louis when he earned this repetition of
playing for a draw and getting getting
them as well but Peter I mean the crazy
part is they're playing Europe meaning
absolutely yeah Jump Right In and tell
us what is this the latest and greatest
in grunfeld theory this is a very
fashionable very fashionable line
against the grinfield where white in
this this is a we can start from the
beginning I guess uh so this is the
grinfield defense which is something
I've been playing since I was about 12
and uh have even against better judgment
written courses
about uh and this is arguably maybe one
of the most important positions of the
grinfield and this move H3 which uh anes
played here is a recent quirky little
way of trying to uh to approach this
opening once again somewhat
non-committal the main moves in this
position would have been the move Rook
B1 or the move Bishop B2 or the move
Bish B3 but H3 keeps all of your options
intact and uh what what they're
discussing here is I think the correct
way for black to play this is also what
I recommend in the course uh check Queen
A3 D5 kn 5
castles and this is a very complicated
position and mvl has experience with it
uh even up to the position they have on
the board right now these moves uh are
not forced but they are very logical
black uh plays Bishop D7 Bishop A4 to
drive the queen to this slightly awkward
looking Square trades the Knight for the
bishop P E2 and now white goes Bishop G5
we're still as you can see on your
screen we're still following the game
between uh Sam seian and Maxim gra
played uh last year here and clearly he
uh should be very well acquainted with
this this is a very very sharp grinfield
it's uh the type of position a grinfield
player from the black side normally
enjoys playing because there is a lot of
uh scope for counterplay but against an
in incredibly well prepared opponent uh
such as Anish you're still fighting for
equality for now but you should be okay
I think if you play precisely although I
feel I may know the answer Tanya I feel
like a lot of our audience wants to ask
the question why didn't black win The
Rook on A1 yeah that's uh that's
something that uh might seem attractive
at first glance in particular let's say
in this position you can just take on F3
hello and then take I'm a rook up take a
rook for the bishop which we're being
taught that you know Rook is Five Pawns
and Bishop is maybe three and a three
and a half on a good day but uh the
threat of Bishop H6 uh the black king
once this bishop is gone the Bishop that
is currently very notable for its
absence on the G7 Square the dark
squares are incredibly uh incredibly
weak you have to deal with the threat of
Bishop P six immediately white also has
a very very strong Center and black spes
just don't impress very much so you
don't like this for black you would not
take the exchange even though materially
for for me uh there are some positions
where you you you you have to commit to
this particular uh exchange uh but this
I really just like and Bishop D7 I I
would prefer in a hard bit here okay I
would agree with Peter on that that
bishop and G7 the dark Square Bishop is
the heart and soul in these positions
and sure you win the exchange but with
all those dark Square weaknesses you
might just end up losing the game I
think it's important to not be
materialistic and I know you're a pawn
Grabber it would have taken me 10 years
not to take that Rook I mean 10 years of
experience I mean because you get to
play F6 and Rook F7 and you you tuck and
you hold on until the material speak it
might not be losing as such but it's uh
I think it also leads to positions which
grinfield players tend to tend to
dislike and mvl is also I think of of a
mind to to play actively it looks like
the players have reached a unique
position because the novelty the the the
game disappeared what you referen Sam
Sean what happened Peter uh honestly
they're doing this a little bit too
quickly for me to uh to to keep up and
uh for the first time I'm I'm I'm trying
to be Maurice here and I'm on yet
another level I understand I will never
be Maurice and it's impossible to be
Maurice if you're not Marice I there's
no way there's no way to keep up in
particular with Anish uh we saw the
clock uh on our screen just now mvl is
done to 20 minutes and Anish I think
gained a minute and a half two yeah so
um there you see it that's a different
that's a different board but yeah Anish
currently has not spent a single moment
thinking M H7 H6 H6 as H6 has been
played on our screens there um once
again you have to you know having yaser
in uh in the studio you have to ask why
the P4 hasn't been hasn't been I I guess
we can still wait for a move and pick it
up next move would be my best argument
because honestly breaking this Pawn
chain on e4 and D5 should be something
that you you absolutely need to do so
yeah the question of exactly why we
aren't doing it uh
I don't really have an answer oh good
good good good because if you both were
going to gang up on me and tell me oh I
don't like taking Pawn we've got issues
I mean there's there's a way fight
there's a way to find out of course but
I was trying to trying to avoid it but
it seems to be playable honestly seems
not to be a mistake yeah and the the
engine suggestion would be I I
eventually might have lended on this but
I think wow this is such a tricky
position I think what the engine and I'm
assuming Anish as well because Anish is
clearly still very much in in book is
suggesting here is that obviously we
don't lose we don't want to lose both
the E4 and the D5 pawn and now we have
this very annoying threat of Rook E1 uh
attacking the queen on e4 the queen on
e4 despite being on the very very
Central Square it doesn't really have
very good squares to run to uh you could
even envisage some scenarios where it
gets caught for instance if we make some
kind of a stupid move here uh you can
you can already see just how Frau with
danger these things are it's it seems to
be sorry D7 still D7 still exist but if
you throw in Rook C7 and you know King
f8 something like Rook C7 here might be
or Bishop even even simply Bishop takes
C7 and then we start running with the D-
Pawn so this is potentially very very
dangerous for black mvl has included H6
and he went Rook E1 yeah and on on the
topic of how dangerous this queen is how
is your queen
tra and this is maybe why you should
have taken on e4 in the previous move
because this is I I wanted to ask you
this is no longer available yeah your
queen is trapped here that's that's
pretty clear but that variation where
you went Queen takes E4 just a moment
ago and then you went Queen D2 I'm of
course going to play Rook to d8 right
because I want to and I've got the D1
Square covered so no Rook D1 to protect
you and I'm sitting there scratching my
head yeah that's White's Play It's
surprisingly quiet white just says yes
D5 is incredibly important so I will I
will spend another Tempo on the Move
Rook C5 and reestablish our threat of
Rook E1 and B Bishop takes E7 next and
yeah as we can see on a if I if I stand
aside a little bit and let Dogfish talk
it's it's still zeros unsurprisingly
because everything is zeros these days
but black has to be precise and I'm
guessing mvl was slightly surprised by
something because H6 uh the engine
clearly disagrees with this and Rook F1
probably has been a bit of a a bit of
a I mean this has been is a this is an
awesome prep by Anish giri look at the
clock he's got more time than what he
started with he continues to put the
pressure continues to Blitz out the
moves and this is so uncomfortable for
maxim who actually is one of the biggest
grinfield Experts of all times uh to be
at 18 minutes right now and handling
this speed and this aggressive play with
white uh rookie 3 you pointed out is the
big threat on the board The Black Queen
would have no Escape Route The Bishop's
attack you don't care about that and
we've got a move on the board he Rook C8
which apparently is arguably a losing
mistake because now white suddenly can
take on E7 the point being that after
Rook takes E1 Rook takes E1 this bishop
is still not hanging because after Queen
E7 sorry Rook takes C E7 we
have Rook C1 C8 here and this is why we
played H3 all those moves ago right so
that we don't get made it on the back
Rank and the bishop on f8 is completely
uh unprotectable very important note
here is that the bishop on A4 is so much
out of the game because of the bishop
the pawn on B5 that we can never play we
can never play rookie 7 E8 so this is a
big moment then Peter if Anish spots
Bishop E7 and the tactics that onso it
could mean game over for maxim it seems
it seems incredibly bad yeah Bishop B7
and the big the biggest problem for for
black in this position is that if you
don't have a good reply immediately the
D Pawn will just decide the game right
D6 D7 yeah maybe he is planning to play
Bishop C3 I was wondering if maybe he
thinks Bishop C3 saves him but now wait
a minute I got to call a Timeout on this
one I wanted to take the Rook now you
want to take my Rook on E1 and spend two
tempy come on Peter we don't believe
Bishop C3 yeah and this is the danger of
playing incredibly forcing variations
where your opponent knows them so much
better than you do because mvl was even
following his own game he clearly knows
about this line he's clearly happy with
this line to play twice against very
strong players uh and then he gets
slightly surprise somewhere and two
moves later he is now wow one one
correct move away this is a big moment
here it is because you said it very well
just a moment ago you said that mvl is
one of the world's great excuse me Peter
greld grunfeld players I've been
learning from him for for for years
honestly like I have never seen Maxim
VRA in so much trouble and so much
pressure on the clock and the board in a
grinfield before this exactly and you
just saw Anish turn his head go wait a
minute you can't do this I think he's
he's already zoned B takes E7 and he's
saying it's going to happen yes dude you
know Bishop E7 you're you're toast
you're
done wow what a shock um we've got to
continue our look around the board we'll
uh let uh let him stew I'd love to see
if Anish finds Bishop E7 on this I mean
this could be a decisive decisive moment
for this game we'll definitely keep an
eye on it but you're I mean look if
you've already seen H3 Rook E1 you're
seeing Bishop E7 are and we could see it
on his face right it's it's on his
radar uh I'm going to jump to the game
between uh Sam and Jan and uh Peter I'm
just going to jump it over to you
because everything looks normal except
there's a black Pawn on D3 like what
yeah this is uh this is another one
which which looked quiet for for moment
and is no longer looks quiet at all uh
this has been an English opening where
uh uh Sam played C4 uh Knight F6 Knight
C3 E5 and uh this line I think has been
popularized or at least this approach uh
against the uh E5 Bishop B4 lines was
popularized I think by Magnus in
particular beating beating Faby in one
of the games of their the final day of
the the world championship match in one
of the the playoff games Bishop takes E3
but Magnus I think was taking with the D
pawn and then trying for this kind of a
slow grindy plan with uh but B takes C3
is much more concrete and uh once again
it seems like both of them are quite
well prepared because uh uh they got to
yeah they got to a very strange looking
positions incredibly quickly which
normally is a sign that they both are
aiming for something like that so an
immediate confrontation here in the
center as you can see black prepares and
immediately goes for the break with C6
and D5 uh White uh respond by trading
everything and finally securing the king
position and then Knight C6 and in this
position interesting uh kind of a
skirmish begins because uh Sam plays
Rook E1 and Yan responds to it with a
very cute little seemingly Pawn
sacrifice which isn't a sacrifice at all
because if you take if you take on e4
you immediately lose to this very very
cute tactic with the uh the skewer only
on the dile winning black quite a bit of
material so after E4 Knight D4 Knight D4
CD4 was played Bishop
F5 uh and and whing white to win a pawn
but maybe not a ATT not a very
attractive Pawn Yeah you you really
dislike this for white because white
ends up yes white has more pawns on the
board but this bishop is going to be
very very sad and this Knight on D5 is
just so beautiful I think uh I'm
actually very surprised the engine
doesn't prefer this for black me too we
have it it has been played but I think
there was a little switch up of the move
order instead of taking on E7 directly
he decided to trade on on C8 Anish giri
going for Rook takes rook and after the
recapture he takes on E7 and Peter what
does that change it a lot uh it's still
it's still very strong but I guess it
gives black slightly more options
because in particular now the engine
suggest this move Bishop A4
D1 uh which addresses one of the things
that we were talking about earlier the
fact that the bishop on A4 just had no
future it had nothing at all to to look
forward to White is still better but at
least you now have to pay some attention
to to your own Queen side the the engine
suggestion currently is to take on A7
just allow black to take on F3 twice and
then bring the queen back and honestly
this still looks like it probably should
win for white because we've preserved
our very beautiful Center the dwn is
still ready to run up the board and
there aren't really any checks on the
king side to speak of so you probably
actually have to trade Queens here with
black and go into an end game of Pawn
down which you should expect to lose
frankly against good play but compared
to the positions he would have been
getting after Bishop B7 immediately this
is maybe an improvement which tells you
something about how critical mvl
situation is and yes it felt like that
was the first moment that Anish was out
of his prep right when he slowed down in
a critical position takes his time but
he didn't find the most accurate the
most precise Way Forward which would
have given him a much bigger Advantage
well here's the problem I mean I as I
see it at least Anish has a choice of
wins in other words in this position
after the move Bishop D1 or even
allowing the move Bishop D1 what Peter
said makes perfect sense Queen takes A7
another move that just caught my eye
immediately what do I do when I'm a head
material and I'm so impressed by how
powerful this Pawn is I'm thinking I'm
winning with Queen D2 here I'm winning
with Queen A7 so you know you got your
choice of wins but I agree the immediate
Bishop E7 from what we saw was just far
more accurate and more convincing but
maybe this is the more human approach
like you're pointing out you want to get
rid of as many pieces without allowing
those lines with the black Bishop
jumping on to C3 the defenses that we
saw and this just looks cleaner to Anish
and to my eyes I I got no problems here
sign me up I'm ready on this one yeah
this is uh uh we were talking about it
ourselves Peter mvl we never saw mvl get
caught out like this in a groom fold
and by the way uh through the magic of
Television we get this Rook takes C8
this the takes E7 yeah and that was
where we thought the immediate Bishop E7
without the inclusion of The Rook trades
that stops your Bishop D1 that you're
mentioning but even so uh Peter is this
the engine's not that
enthusiastic yeah this is this is still
much better for white and uh it seems
like Anish has gone for for the move
Queen D2 instead of Queen takes A7 also
a very understandable decision
immediately getting the Queens off the
board not allowing black to break up uh
the the structure on the queen side and
honestly it's a bit shocking that the
engine doesn't start by immediately
saying white is completely winning white
looks completely winning frankly right
but it hinges I think on the fact that
if you play the immediate move D5 D6
which I think you would like to play 1
D7 now black is in time to play B5
before and establish some sort of a
blockade and black is still of healthy
Pawn down this is not going to be fun
for for M to defend but compared to some
of the previous POS previous positions
you can sort of envisage a way out you
can see how this improves for black
which I don't think was true at all
about some of the early options that
Anish perhaps has has missed all right
so mvl down upon with a bishop pair and
he's got to try to hold this position
but there's action on the other boards
as well uh I'm just going to do a
flashback if you don't mind to uh Fabby
versus uh ala Al Resa when we left it we
just saw the flexible treatment H3 Queen
E7 let's catch up with the players
Knight C3 Queen E2 and interestingly it
looks like both players want to go k
queenside no I take that back after I
see the move B4 but I see that Fabby is
not anxious to go kingside and he's
keeping sometimes your king is safest in
the center and maybe he's just waiting
for the right I mean now he's not going
to go alongside queenside castling
anymore that's not allowed but we might
be seeing some big vlads no castling
Chess By Fabby in this one there we go
there we go um Peter jump in I mean uh a
very surprising and dare I say it
unorthodox approach by Fabby to this
Berlin position yeah and I think we
should welcome this with open arms
because this is going to be a very sharp
fight why clearly uh is trying to
achieve something on the queen side
ala's response to it is basically he
says no I don't believe your B5 break
does anything I'm a bit shocked by the
fact that uh the reply to B5 appears to
be actually taking I think most people
in this position would just immedi
immediately play c65 shutting it down
but uh the engine thinks black has
absolutely nothing to worry about and
should just take and maybe even throw in
the move Knight F4 ignoring the fact
that the A7 Pawn is hanging with check
yeah it's a Brave New World where you
know engines just give up Pawns in every
single position but generally speaking
Yeah we we're here now this is just
going to be a very very interesting
fight white is not entirely happy I
don't think even castling King side
because you uh you you have to
eventually but uh you're also going to
be faced with even let's say after the
immediate Knight F4 but black is not
forced to go Knight F4 so quickly you
can definitely try to prepare the move
F7
F5 and just how uh do these two players
match up Tanya let's take a look at
their head-to-head score Fabiano caran
world number two currently with 12 wins
and five losses I would have guessed
that even closely I would have thought
it' be much more closer right much more
tight but it looks like Fabby is a big
favorite at least on paper in Rapid
chess yes no question wow 12 wins did
you anticipate that no but I think it
once again speaks to the the something
you and I Yer I think have a very
intimate relationship with you know
start playing them early you know start
playing them when they're very young
beat them when they're young yeah and
then you can have a a good score for it
is the first part of your career because
you you've accumulated some yeah you
feel a cushion blast yeah there when
these two players play do you also feel
you ask that it is a clash of styles
Fabiano Carana with his uh classic
approach of building on small strategic
advantages and playing it flawlessly and
Ali resa's aggressive approach I do feel
that I do I do feel that the that the
players have uh different approaches to
chess and uh I'm not going to call it a
generational Clash because you know when
we talk generational class I'm talking
20 years these two are much closer in
age than that but yeah I I Tanya I do I
I feel a little bit uh the two different
approaches two different approaches and
the position that we have on the board
who do you think it suits more
um very hard to say I I think maybe ala
because I am envisaging uh some kind of
a really sharp fight and as I was the
thing that black wants to do the most I
think here is to be able to play F5 but
not just play F5 but be able to
recapture with the pawn which is
currently impossible because that loses
a full a full Knight so I'm even
considering something kind of outlandish
move like Queen E7 E8 here just to
prepare F5 so that once the same tradeit
happens this queen will be connected to
the Knight on H5 and weirdly even the
engine doesn't hate that move which I
didn't expect I I was very much
expecting to be shouted at by by by the
engine here but it doesn't it's a very
interesting position and a position I
think that you you want to watch when
you when you see players playing the the
Berlin anti Berlin uh you don't often
get positions which should be as fun as
this one so that's it's funny while you
were talking I forcibly reminded of a
book that I was recently re reading
chess Odyssey by my friend Jeremy Silman
and you know Jeremy sitting there saying
when you want to do something just go
ahead and do it and if you don't mind
playing F5 again sure taking with the
pawn dropping your knight and not
forgetting about F5 F4 so you do get
your piece back there's a C5 Square oh
there is a C5 Square unfortunately
unfortunately but it's an idea that you
have to have in mind it can work open G
file is so compelling absolutely but
speaking of open G files there might be
one and another game because we're
getting a big update Sam Sean another
huge moment Yan Nai has just made a big
blunder we didn't a very natural looking
move uh and Peter 86 was played hitting
the bishop and you're showing the line
uh take it away oops uh yeah that's
that's a bit of a misclick and honestly
it's a bit of a strange mistake for for
Yan to make because uh you this is a a
very known Motif in which occurs in a
lot of openings actually the idea of
first bringing the G7 Pawn out you
destroy a little bit of black queen king
Side by doing uh uh cre creating the
sacrifice and then you take on E6 and
this forces another Pawn out of the way
and this gives you this queen G6 check
uh this exists in the pets there's a lot
of very famous positions in the pets
where this happens and iqp positions in
general I think they feature this tactic
quite a bit so for how finish that off
before we move forward from that
position because I see white has this
huge Advantage yeah I I think you just
go you just go for full material you
don't look for M specifically you just
collect everything eventually you will
pick up that knife because it's also
hanging and you will have uh three
connected pass BS on the king side and a
continued attack on the king side so
it's it's not just that you will be a
head on material you will also be still
very much in the hunt for for the black
king so yeah that that's just completely
unplayable and Bishop H6 played and
really not not a shock I would like whoa
Yan is actually going for this so Yan
apparently wow he's he's calculated
something Peter Knight B4 is so he's
gone live before here and he somehow
feels that this is playable but I don't
know it once again very suspicious you
have to ask yourself how how sure you
would be this is unplayable if you
didn't have the engine running but
honestly I think I would be I think I
would still feel this cannot possibly
work for black I I I'm with you 100% so
let's say the queen stays on this
diagonal and if you pick up the Rook cuz
you've got this bishop E4 yeah So
eventually yeah like check on E G6 and
Bishop E4 you're relying on Queen to C7
is that the only way thank you
Tanya yeah I guess Point
yeah we're getting a lot of updates the
players are just blitzing out their
moves so they they got they got to that
position and uhan is got an expression
like okay let's make a draw like okay
this is a perpet this is not a Perpetual
no no no and uh the most precise way of
doing this and once again I'm wondering
why it very specifically goes Rook E1
with the King on G8 uh and not with the
King on h8 I'm not really very sure Rook
E5 to G5 is it maybe it's to do with
Queen F5 queen queen H7 I think I worked
it out I think if you if you do it uh if
you do it in this position if if you
play Rook E1 here black will play Queen
F5 gotcha and after Queen H6 black will
have the move Queen H7 which we don't
really want to encourage exactly so we
do it uh we do it with the King on G8
and we do it with the pawn on E6 it's
it's even better with the PA on E6
actually because then we don't allow
Rook E8 super
inst one he gets the final piece into
the attack he brings the Rook from A1
takes the time out to join the party
bring all the toys to the nursery and
now there is a massive threat of The
Rook jumping onto the center of the Bard
on E5 toys to the nursery I it's a
nursery you want to be at right now this
is is looking uh like a big attack I
think maybe I know what Yan potentially
missed because I think you you ask
yourself why is Queen F5 not defending
sufficient that and the reason is you
realize that Queen takes F2 is just one
check you don't actually have to stop it
uh it's just one check after
which after which white will still be
able to to land a decisive blow on the
king side but Sam has gone for a
different line which also
which was my first thought and you said
Queen C7 and I thought I overlooked that
so he actually picked up all the pawns
first right right and then he played
Bishop B4 Queen C7 and in this position
he just played A2 A3 a quiet move trying
to drive the Knight to to a very poor
Square you can't allow Bishop to D5
check in other words Knight C6 Queen H6
check and Bishop D5 so he's thinking I'm
going to pick up the
Knight I like it and me too there's no
way for the Knight to actually keep the
D5 Square under control you pick up big
material you win The Rook back and
you've got about a million pounds for a
piece and an open King to attack I like
the way you're thinking to absolutely
yeah black has a way at least to maybe
force the Queens off here if you start
with Queen G7 which looks the more
natural way this I think loses on the
spot because white just wins and Bishop
D5 comes next anywhere
exactly and now Yan is realized like
wait a minute oh kn6 so okay that that
we know loses but Yan apparently isn't
very convinced but yeah Sam will
definitely do this this and then he will
pause to think and I think youran just
makes the move Rook E1 here I don't
think you can make any other move really
you just want it's so natural yeah maybe
Yan thinks Knight E7 will hold because
that does probably force you to cash in
your chips a little bit but this looks
lost it's terrible Queen H7 Rook Queen
H7 probably wins the simplest way to win
here is just to give a check from E6 got
to go if King E8 Queen G8 is a nice
little usage of the pin which allows you
to pick up that rook and if King
f8 we do the same yes it's not even
difficult no so yeah my my pick for the
entire tournament is starting I would
say
poorly and wasn't it V who picked Sam as
yes he did we didn't get
Anastasia uh pick but that we'll be sure
to include her and he's Sam is he's
doing it he and by the way for me Yan is
one of those players who's incredibly
fast yeah he plays quickly regardless
whether he's winning or even when he's
losing when I'm losing I tend to stop
and for players when they're winning as
well they want to be precise and I think
this is one of Jan's biggest strength
and like all strengths it can sometimes
be his biggest weakness as well where we
see sometimes this rash quick play that
messes up an advantage and I wonder if
that move 86 allowing this entire
tactics these sequence of moves I think
it was Blitz out on the board uh it
wasn't a position that Yan wanted but
again just one of those moments where he
doesn't take a pause doesn't slow down
and ends up in this and when you're
playing a rapid game and your opponent
plays a move sacrifices gets up like we
saw Sam savian do you know you're in big
trouble exactly Peter jump in because
you've been a teammate of yan you know
his speed
regardless of whether he's winning or
losing I wanted to say that and weak
honestly uh slightly Tong and chick but
not very much I wanted to say that this
is not actually very fast for him
because he is down to about 15 minutes
from 25 and uh this is not how he plays
when he's playing really really fast
because we've seen him complete games
full games of Chess not just prep full
games of chess with thinking involved
almost with more time than he began with
so this has actually featured featured
some some thinking by him which I think
is not not the greatest sign because I
think this just doesn't pass the sniff
test you should not be going for this no
it's clear uh and uh I'm very shocked
that he allowed this this combination we
haven't even seen all of the games
because we've been rooted by uh this one
by mvl and by fabes let's just jump to
Ray Robson and Jeffrey jang's game
because finally we've got something
that's well prepared quiet classic
uh Peter take it away well this is what
you are worried about when you see
players aiming for for Berlin and pets
this is sorry this is exactly the kind
of a position which uh is very very
topical uh and not very exciting to uh
comment to to because you have to really
drill down to discuss exactly why the
small differences in in peace activity
matter because this is a this is a Petro
which I personally I think it's probably
not very correct but I I call these
Bishop F F5 lines the Chinese Petro
because I think a lot of the young
Chinese players at some point switched
to playing almost exclusively that
against one4 with great success and by
great success I mean they draw they draw
every you don't win very many with black
although you do occasionally when people
over press but uh but you are incredibly
solid and uh you you get these types of
very slow moving uh games where the
structure is entirely symmetrical there
is not going to be uh very many
weaknesses to talk of but to begin with
white has the more active pieces white
has slightly more space and black does
need to be uh careful not to uh not to
allow something something dangerous to
happen but eventually pieces start
coming off which is what we're seeing
here uh trades are happening and this
doesn't look like it's very much for
white honestly it looks like black is
maybe one move away from playing F6 and
then finally being able to start trading
things along the E file which is sort of
the dream in this uh in this line in
general trench warfare but that's not
happening Tanya in the nepo game we
think uh it's about to finish really
soon I mean it really feels like uh Sam
may be the first uh to win this game
because now too late for nappo to think
right I mean he looks what look what
he's facing and rookie W as you called
it out uh joins The Party exctly The
Rook on F7 you don't need to rush with
it he has to pick it up no uh again a
rook lift Rook E4 Rook over and as Peter
was mentioning maybe although that's
looking at things from afar maybe uh 97
was Yan's go-to defense until you see
this and it's really not I don't know if
it was his go-to defense I just think he
missed this entire Bishop 86 and
everything to follow because it's not
really something that you want to allow
on the board even if you see it through
even even if you come to this point of
97 it's not a position that you're
aiming for except Tanya we have in our
database our minds these familiar
patterns and whenever you're playing
against an isolated Queen Pawn position
you're always looking at these
sacrifices Rook Z6 and queen G6 so
something something went wrong uh Peter
yeah I'm I'm reluctant to start making
excuses and players you know in round
one but yeah this is and I just want to
make an argument even that okay you
played H6 you Blended a you you just
tell yourself I will I will feel a bit
silly but I will just play Rook ad d8
here and play and I will continue and
honestly the blockade in the center and
the rest of our pieces are so healthy
that of course the opposition you know
decreased in values because you you
blundered a point in front of your king
but the game very much continuous like
Bishop G5 you play Rook D7 and you start
aiming for end games and no way you go
and and it is over we've got resignation
Yan throws in the toble wow that
happened super fast and we didn't get to
it but there was a game uh between uh
Liam and Wesley as you were mentioning
at the top of the show Peter uh Wesley
is fabulous in these Grand chest tour
he's he's been so incredibly successful
here is on the outside looking in he
really needs a result uh both in this
event as well as the SFI cup and if you
had told me this came out of the Queen's
Gambit accepted I would say yep sure did
no it came out of uh Vienna
and the players have reached a position
where I want to say it's dry but there's
still a lot of fight in the position and
after the move Knight F3 Wesley is
saying wait a minute You' played a
little passively and also yes the the SE
file there are a lot of pieces lined up
on the sea line the rook and C8 eyeing
that bishop and Knight in front of the
Queen the last move A5 hints and further
Pawn Advance B4 kicking out this night I
like Black's position here exactly it
seems like Liam just allowed Wesley uh
initiative and that's the thing too
Peter about these guys is their accuracy
is is stunning and sometimes especially
I'm thinking Magnus uh his accuracy
sometimes just like it's it's astounding
they you give your opponent an
initiative these guys just run with it
yeah and I think Wesley is a perfect
example of that Wesley is and this is a
story we've I think we've covered on on
these shows earlier uh in previous years
I want to say because I haven't really
covered the grunch story this season is
that Wesley is a fabulous player but it
feels like uh he's restricted himself to
this type of play where he makes very
very few mistakes I think he's one of
the cleanest in terms of uh in terms of
lack of uh outright mistakes players in
the world yeah and he wins these games
where you give him a Sniff and he is
just not going to let it go he he wins
these games where like you give him a
little bit out of the opening and then
you're absolutely in a fight for your
life uh but when he was at his absolute
best let's say in like 2015 16 17 I want
to say where he had this absolutely free
flowing style and he showed uh he showed
much more of an attacking mindset I
think he was even better than now and uh
considering how good he is now it's I
think saying something and also
something silly I wanted to mention
because I'm a very silly person this is
probably mathematically the
shortest game in terms of names of
participants I don't think you can
go less than four letters yeah leave so
yeah I think that's probably the the
absolute record yeah speaking of four
letter names I believe giri is in a
little bit of a trouble as well and uh
Peter what you said about Wesley I think
completely agree with that as well
tenacity his tenacity the hardest player
to beat on the circuit but sometimes I
think his desire to keep it solid
surpasses his desire to win uh and that
could be the reason why we see him as
not losing so many games but also not
ending up getting so many points when we
left it we thought he was in control uh
we did see this move Bishop A4 we did
not anticipate Bishop to B4 but
okay A5 Bishop takes A5 Rook takes A2
still looking good yeah I think maybe E6
is a mistake honestly because I I don't
know if if white has actually white does
have a lot here this is not a shocker to
me I think Anish just missed the move
Rook A1 I think he thought he is
basically breaking through E7 E8 resign
yeah but now the Rooks will be uh forc
forced to come off and without the Rook
on E1 that pawn is not quinning oh
that's complete turn around yeah and and
that I think I think if uh n finds Rook
A1 and I think he will find Rook A1
because he doesn't really have very much
else he will be he will be forced to
play you you just save it from here and
maybe maybe Anish thought Knight B1 is
very strong but now with the pin along
the back rank uh the engine even
suggests you can play Bishop B3 which is
a shocker but you can also just go with
the King towards the E8 square or Play
Bishop F6 because with that PIN along
the back rank right wh's attacking
attacking prospects are severely
diminished so yeah this is uh this is a
huge turnaround from the position here
after a55 Rook A2 where if white just
makes a very natural looking move D5 D6
stopping D7 is only really possible by
giving up a second pawn and I'll take
that yes and yes black establishes some
kind of a well you can't call it a
blockade but you two pawns yeah but you
have establish some control over over
the things here but you're still that's
a way saying you're not going to resign
immediately
you don't have to resign immediately but
yeah it's it should be Nur to a victory
but the move E6 Rook A1 oh my gosh
that's the cold shower Rook A1 huge and
a bit uncharacteristic I always feel
that Anish is very good at finishing
these kind of games off a move like D6
uh and it's such a natural move it's not
even a very hard to find move I mean
you've got you've got two options D6 and
E6 right and in this particular case it
happens that your Bishop just by
circumstances uh covering the
promotional Square d8 so you're right
Peter you play you play D6 you're forced
to play B4 you go Bishop takes B4 you go
yeah yada yada yada you get to play for
aot a little while you know you
eventually will win this position
because you are two healthy pawns ups
and you will need to blunder something
very very dramatic not to Win It Rook A1
E6 big blunder Rook A1 that is and I
think it's on the board quite the turn
around round and for mvl what a save
what a save but I've seen Maxim do these
uh magical things on the board it was at
the T of Steel rapid where he's down a
rook against with it and he turns it
around and wins the game and that's not
the only Rook down game that I've seen
Maxi turn around and I think Peter you
know the ones that I'm talking about
these are the kind of positions where
he's so resourceful but again I felt
like D6 it's it's it should not have
been that uh it should not have been a
Miss by Anish sorry we're we we're
getting so many exciting games and I
really thought that this one was going
to be our Marquee matchup the game
between fabbi and Ali Raza and as you
said Peter I mean it's all about these
attacks I'm going to play B5 you're
going to play F5 G5 um I agreed with you
by the way I like that move Queen E8
just that Ali Raza took a different
approach he put his Pawn on F6 first his
prep and and now he's getting ready I
was about to say he's getting ready for
his kingside break he went another way
G5 jump in Peter yeah he he played
slightly slower he played a very similar
uh oops approach but uh slightly slower
he didn't play Queen E8 here uh in this
position he played F6 Rook fd1 Queen F7
and I think the notable thing here to uh
to pay attention to is why sort of
declared his intentions on the queen
side here you play B4 you play Rook B1
you say I'm going to do something the
queen side and then Fabi spends the next
five moves shuffling mainly in the
center and on the king side allowing
black to basically achieve pretty much
everything uh everything you want and
yes now the pawn is on A5 but black
really with the amount of pieces next to
the king and very very importantly I
think with the queen on the seventh
meaning that you you you cannot really
even even entertain any thoughts of
these of these
sacrifices because black always has
Queen B7 in the end yeah nice uh so
Fabby after some thought I assume went
for Fairly fairly unhappy choice of
giving up uh the remaining bishop and
playing D3
D4 but the thing is it's still not very
clear what he's aiming for the black
queen side is extremely solid it's very
difficult to open anything up on the
queen side and black is one move away
from asking asking very direct questions
he's on your doorstep with the move G5
G4 and I it's on the board he did go for
it a very direct move it's just so much
easier to play with black and I want to
come down to the point that you made
earlier that this feels like more of an
Ali Resa position where uh he's it's
Dynamics and it's just easier to build
the attack while Black's King on the
queen side extremely safe agreed yeah
black is so solid there and even if you
spend a whole Tempo playing a move like
Bishop C8 for whatever reasons you want
to play Bishop C8 your king is so safe
and look at the clock yes yeah let me
two and a half minutes done for Fabby in
a difficult position to defend he's
trying to open up the position on the
queen side but he just does feels like
he doesn't have enough resources to be
able to do that alira a good seven
minutes so he's got enough time to
really find the right way here uh
interesting question Tanya I just throw
that right back at you there ab and he's
pausing because I think a lot of people
play the move AB automatically
recapturing but would you have been
attracted to UND doubling your C pawns
with a C7 takes B6 and the reason you
say a lot of people are attracted to the
a pawn taking it because you get a Side
Pawn to the towards the center of the
board and you have this idea of moving
the king one step ahead to B7 and if
required your Rook from d8 can slide
over to the a file and defend everything
I think both are extremely tempting
option I really liked Peter's approach
of taking it with the c Pawn so that
your queen is not only an attacker on
the king side but also defends your king
I have to say if I had to make a split
second decision I might have been more
tempted to take take it with the a pawn
what about you yasa I split second
decision I'd probably have taken with
the c Pawn just because I like the
defensive uh possibility and again
Black's King for me Peter is super safe
and that open G half open G file about
to be
open I think I think one one reason one
reason for taking with the shewn is also
like ABAB you have open the a file for
right so there are some thoughts perhaps
of playing something like2 Rook A1 you
trying to play Queen A6 and creating a
maing attack it's probably not going to
be fast enough because things will be
happening on the other side of the board
which is just happening much much
quicker than anything that we can
describe here but there is definitely a
temptation to go C takes B but I can
understand it and also as as we were
discussing you're it's so ingrained I
think in in in in chess players to
capture towards the center that you have
to have sort of lifechanging
reasons not to do it and uh I think I
think this is why he didn't even
hesitate for for too long what about you
Peter would you have captured it with
the seon if you have to take an
instinctive decision in this honestly
probably not no I I I saw the engine
preferring C xb6 and I was kind of
reluctant we would put it on the board
because I I want things compact I want I
want the proper the proper approach to
structural structural things is very
very deep in me I think a more human
approach to take with the Aon but it
will be interesting to see if Fabby can
create some Dynamics with this open aine
now and that Queen on F1 it's a
retreating move but watch out because
it's aiming at the other side of the
board Queen F1 eyeballing A6 while while
we're still here there's there's a
massive issue with this because black
can black can even throw in Bishop C4
here I'm not a big fan of this queen F1
I think it's it's Fabby playing on two
minutes it's a very difficult position
he also doesn't really have much time to
uh to delve deeply and to try to find
the best play and this this just looks
horrible because now you you completely
abandon any dreams of including your
queen in the attack and black just
starts doubling on the G5 I wanted to
ask Peter come on just double up no it
looks horrible it looks frankly
borderline lost and also let's point out
the basic but important tactic if white
was to recapture on F3 with the queen
Peter that's also disaster because now
The Rook jumps onto G3 and you're
suddenly secured on the third rank
losing material yeah there goes a KN
ouch um okay with so many things going
on we're just going to jump quickly to
the Ray Robson game where we saw nothing
was happening for the longest time but
uh somehow uh Rey has managed to
sacrifice Ry by the way uh is coming off
a mixed year he won the Czech masters
with some fabulous play we had a nice
little party here to celebrate his
victory in St Louis but then a little
bit disappointing at the US Championship
what's going on Peter well he's trying
to uh they're both this is move 20 the
very very committal decision was taken
on move 26 and they at that point were
down to to six minutes and Ray is sort
of correctly appreciating that he is
running out of time to do something on
the king side if black is allowed to
play Rook A8 for instance then F7 F6
everything will get traded down the one
open file on the board and game will be
drawn so he goes F4 here luring the
queen in and gaining some Tempe
attacking it which is honestly an
interesting thing to do and I think it
hinges very much on this move Queen H6
because other squares honestly look kind
of dodgy to me uh and but the queen on
H6 you can for instance continue by
playing Rook H3 okay and it starts
looking iffy for black right you you
start wondering yeah you you start
wondering just how safe that Queen on H6
is and let's say you make one natural
looking move here I wanted to suggest it
and you allow Rook F1 and suddenly
knight6 check is a threat Knight F4 is a
threat and if you play something like
Queen G5 you lose immediately to Rook G3
and your G7 Pawn is UN indefensible so
uh it's an interesting idea and the fact
that engine holds this by starting by
playing Knight C8 I think specifically
so that you can play Queen G5 and after
Rook G3 you are no longer losing the G7
Pawn because the Knight is protecting it
but as you can see the engine isn't even
doesn't help hate it all that much it
just says that yes black can things
under keep things under control by
juggling his pieces very very accurately
but if you have to start making moves
like Rook H6 here and after let's say
Knight G4 I assume the Rook has to go to
H4 uh it doesn't like you you got to get
that feel of going um this is not easy
honestly in Practical terms I very much
like this decision of of playing A4
because it changes the N nature of the
game uh very very dramatically and
suddenly forces uh forces Jeffrey to to
uh solve concrete decisions instead of
just sort of autop piloting until that
moment I think his play was very easily
understood and uh he could pilot it
quite
comfortably had played here Rook H3 yeah
uh trying to trying to land this very
beautiful tactic but this was this will
not be blundered and in fact the engine
says after Queen G5 now black is doing
quite well because you should played
Knight G4 yeah Knight G4 is not uh is
not the prescribed solution here even
though it still looks kind of scary
after Rook G3 like you have to be
convinced you're not getting mated after
something like Knight H6 check or Knight
gf6 check here yeah you you you could
get lost in in Alice and Wonderland here
because at first blush you're seeing all
of these night jumps and you're kind of
convincing yourself like I've got
something I would I would be very very
scared here with black uh but and in
particular they will be playing this
extremely complicated position on very
very low times so right um this one is
definitely uh the one to keep an eye on
because it could explode at any moment
there are certain players by the way if
you're playing against a Jeffrey Jang
and you play the move F2 F4 you're
trying to get Jeffrey out of his comfort
zone if Jeffrey gets into that place
where he's going to be unaffected you're
not you're not going to beat him so you
want to make something double-edged and
risky and let's face it Ray Ray is a bit
of a gambler he's he's got that streak
in him to to go for this Palm sacrifice
and very often in these time controls
gambles like these seem to work out even
better in the rapid in the rapid because
you don't have that much time to counter
it and the point that Peter was making I
think it's really important that you
just change the Dynamics of the position
the position has been solid uh there's
an autopilot mode in which the players
are playing but suddenly it's about
calculation it's about being more
concrete and we see Rook G3 was on the
board with a big idea of the KN jumping
the queen moves out of the way to H4 and
look and and now he's gone one mistake
and he's gone and it's I think it's
findable as well because yes you don't
really like trading attacking pieces but
it's a threee of calculation which is
really not that difficult what he missed
I'm sure is that a queen trap yes what
he missed I'm sure is this move R G4 and
I think you miss it not because it's
difficult but because I think your brain
refuses to start calculating from a
trade right you're worried about getting
mated here you're not worried about tra
trapping your queen and things so you
start by calculating all of those Knight
H6 Knight gf6 checks here and you do
need your Rook on E6 to cover those
squares and you think if my opponent has
to start trading here I'm okay of course
and you kind of ignore those variations
but yeah Rook e six there is no choice
you have to take with the Knight KN the
six check it doesn't really matter where
the King goes Rook four next move and
you don't even get a rook and a knight
part you just get a yeah you two pieces
or something but the crazy part too is
with the queen on H4 Tanya you have it
in the back of your mind you're thinking
hey I've got E1 covered when The Rook
was on E1 there was a pair of Rooks on
the board so you really do close your
mind and you're not thinking of you're
only thinking about safety of your king
not the safety of your queen I think
this is how this mistakes mistake happen
wow it's also adapting yourself
psychologically from a very strategic
fight going into this very concrete
direct play which isn't uh isn't the
easiest thing to do and even though
there were defenses we saw an immediate
collapse with Queen H4 and this is a big
moment now what I do know about Ray
Robson is that he is a bit of a tactical
genius he he finds these ideas I've seen
him when it comes to these attacking
positions he didn't just as a
commentator there you have it he you
were about to say one of the great
puzzle Rush players exactly and he's
he's got records in puzzle rush so if he
if you had told him but look at the
clock I think that was a factor he's
down to about a minute and finding this
Rook G4 I think Rook G4 once you show it
Peter you can't unsee it but to see it
from afar isn't that
easy wow and uh now has has it turned
completely in Jeff fa no it's it's a
pretty balanced position actually
because yeah V still has a lot of
activity on theing side you still have
to play very precisely and the engine
currently is suggesting you go queen7
and you cannot really play Rook F6
because it gets stuck there but you can
just give this exchange up to get rid of
that very very dangerous Knight on E5
and this one is coming to E4 later this
if you pick a side here I guess you pick
black but it's still pretty balanced but
we're being told that Fabby is in a lot
of trouble in our in our game of the day
and yeah it looks there's a mate in one
being threatened in that last position
that we have we left it we saw it t with
Queen F1 and we looked at takes takes he
did Play Bishop C4 by the way did uh Ali
Rea and after doubling on the G file
well here it comes Rook takes
F3 bang which was a threat in any case
and uh if we just do a quick action
replay of the move King to H2 there
which was played against the idea of a
rook takes Knight but it happened anyway
because the other Rook jumps into the
attack here takes the Knight H3 is
defended but not anymore is and queen F1
you don't even have the square for the
queen to come into defense no we already
gave the Queen the boot a few moves back
is this yeah this
isus the move that probably ends the
game the fastest is the move Rook H3
just creating this very very strong idea
of a four of3 by the way I think the
queen you we we can see that the players
just blitzed out their last few moves
there but it looks like the Queen got
hacked off the board ala instead goes
for a very very understandable Choice as
well just goes Rook f one check and then
F four of3 in the end there attacking
The Rook on H2 if you gave white one
tempo to stop to stop a four F3 maybe
you could have had a game but uh yeah
this is going to be results coming in by
the way we are just being told uh Wesley
lost the game at a moment when we
thought Wesley was getting a bit of the
upper hand we'll have to revisit that
one but we're going to stay with Fabby
and Ali Raza for now because we've got
two Rooks versus the queen in uh this uh
game and many reasons to stay on to this
one an exciting position a great game by
Ali Rea and ala was your pick and Faby
was mine you're doing well on that one
well Tanya you know you're going to get
a participation try don't worry don't
worry yeah our board is our board is
somewhat behind the screen but yeah you
can see on the screen black has this
extremely safe Ging
uh which is the one thing you have to
pay attention to when you're playing
this queen against two Rooks positions
and by way did I want to tell you guys
that you should play a takes B6 have a
very safe King position how many pawns
is that not
enough not enough for I mean this
is this is four pawns but we're also
getting an update that NASA Anastasia
our commentator in on the ground yes he
also picked Fabby to win this one but it
doesn't look like it's going to be a
great start now for you and I and
Fabby correct uh but how easy is this as
a conversion queen versus two Rooks it's
pretty easy the four exra Ps yeah the
difference in King safety is just such
that once you start pushing something
things just collapse and yeaha having
done the the Needful Things on in the
center and on the queen side securing
the king making sure there are no checks
he's not just threatening to play H4 H3
and so on and there's just no stopping
it because do you want to go B5 C as
well we everything you want all of it
yes the B5 and C4 check inclusive with
the quiny one check also picks up the
last remaining he didn't say it but it's
not it's not required it's not really a
Miss yeah H3 is coming in next I don't
know Pawn grubbers uh calling this a
mistake is too harsh you grab a pawn to
push a pawn and that's what oliv res is
doing now and the Rooks are tied down to
defend each other you can't even get to
the H file no and that's it he wants to
make a move but Fabiano resigns he knows
there's nothing else to play for Ali
Resa takes a big win yes by the way I
mean we're seeing a lot of decisive
games and what happened between Anish
and MV because Anish was winning and
then it was any Rook A1 happened Peter
yeah I think I think the the whole game
was decided on that choice between E6
and D6 had he played D6 I think he would
have won but as it happened mvl escapes
giving us our first draw of the
tournament one of the the crazy games uh
of if you had told me when we started
our show and we had gotten into the show
that the draw was between Anish and MBL
when we knew it was over it's like no no
wa what and Maxine he's got to feel the
relief right now it was a game that he
got stuck in the start but then managed
to find the resources there's one more
game remaining it is between Ray Robson
and Jeffrey jong a very tensed position
and what's the stock situation the
players down to under a minute but
there's uh extra an exchange here for
Ray but somehow when um Jeffrey gave up
his exchange he didn't get the second
Pawn Peter yeah if we just briefly
return to the position we were
discussing earlier and and then we'll
just Watch What Happens because that was
a important Turning Point uh I was
suggesting Rook takes C5 needed to be
played it wasn't so they're basically
playing this the version of the position
we're discussing but with white having
one an extra Pawn an extra Pawn okay so
let's just uh 25 seconds so why then
it's so many pieces on the board and
with the knights and the active position
that they are it's so easy to miss a KN
jump in these kind of positions and walk
into a fork but as you said it is an
extra exchange but I really like Black
Knights on the center of the board it
feels like it should be enough
compensation weirdly it feels still like
a three result game even though white is
clearly much much better and it
shouldn't be but it feels that with that
Knight on e4 which cannot be challenged
by any of the white pawns uh and as
little time as they do have it really
does feel like it it's possible to lose
this with white maybe not with the
Queens off though and the queen trade
has just been offered by by by Jeffrey
jeffre and W 10 seconds for Ray Robson
he needs to take a decision do you keep
the Queens on the board trying to create
some play or do you go into an end game
he decides to go for
it uh Rey for those of you who aren't
familiar with Ray's play uh yeah try try
him as a teammate because he gets into
time trouble and boy he's used to going
down I have seen him make a move with a
single second on his clock here in St
Louis uh on multiple occasions actually
remarkable and the current position how
is it assessed how do you assess it how
does the computer assess it Peter what
is still better of course due to the
fact that he has more Rooks but I think
it's a position that you can definitely
you defend because uh that Knight on e4
is very very strong one thing I probably
wouldn't play here is F6 F5 because I
think that gives white the E5 Square for
the Knight I think giving white knight3
knight5 is unnecessary it doesn't spoil
very many things but I would prefer to
maybe not commit to it just yet Peter
you said commentator's
curs but I was going to say that you
know you're talking about these extra
Rooks when You' got the extra Rooks on
the board you want to open up lines does
white have to start not aiming for
advancing and pushing some pawns on the
queen side to try to get more activity
more lines for The Rook absolutely yeah
you do need to you do need to open some
some files some files for the Rooks
either with the C4 break or maybe even
with the G4 break now that there is a
Pawn on F5 for us to try and uh yeah
undermine but as you see black
immediately stops this by playing H5 and
Ray goes H4 which does away with any
breaks on the king side I guess so if he
wants to win this game now he will have
to open up the queen side at some
point well again uh having secured or
locked down if you will both the center
and the King side uh with this move H5
it it comes back to what you're saying
Tanya you're going to have to play for
C3
C4 and uh to open up the lines for the
Rooks otherwise your Rooks are stuck or
defend the C pawn and go A4 B4 B5 it it
kind of comes to this idea of trump
trying to open up get as many files for
The Rook as possible otherwise you're
just not playing for a win the knights
are jumping does he want to get the
other Knight to G4 is this some kind of
a maneuver where you defend the E5
Square the penetration with the White's
Knight but you're also eyeing that G4
Square for your own night I love the
Knight on G4 I think the Knight on G4 is
not only as you said defending E5 but
it's intrusive the white king just kind
of feels like oh wait a minute it's
heading there yes it's coming
yeah and
by the way uh Jeffrey is one of those
players uh he has a way of moving that
lulls you to sleep he it feels like he's
not doing anything and His Hands kind of
make this languishing kind of moves and
then suddenly you realize you got no
time on your
clock and uh look at those three nights
on the fourth rank it's quite a picture
that Jeffrey has created with his hand
movement as you're pointing out exactly
uh and yes why has the extra exchange
but I'm starting to like Black's
position the extra minutes on the clock
the last move Rook H7 was a signal that
maybe Jeffrey was ready to play G5 and
maybe H4 and Ray said I'm not going to
give you that I went he went Rook H1 a
kind of a defensive move but uh it's
still about the queen side and uh can he
play C3 C4 one day he's got to do that
he has to find a way to advance the
pawns on on the queen side create some
lines for The Rook but this is
prediction time does this end in a
decisive result or are we going to have
a draw here just a
draw sorry Tanya but yeah I do feel that
uh both players are going to
play safely accurately and uh I don't
see Ray as you know he pushed his luck
with that4 any he was almost rewarded to
success but uh no I think he's kind of
happy with the outcome it was a good
fight and it's a good thing that right
now he's not aware of the fact that he
miss trapping his opponent's Queen yes
which would have of course been a
completely different game really nice
idea pointed out by Peter with the Rook
to G4 uh some moves back but this is a
completely different position now and
the last few moves it feels like black
has made all the progress while white
still hasn't managed to find the squares
for the Rooks and again uh if our
understanding is correct that we're
going to be playing for C4 one day and
breaking on the queen side well no
progress has been made in that direction
by the way Peter is that something that
has plagued you in your career it
certainly has plagued me I've made a
move only to become aware of the fact
after I've made the move that I missed a
golden opportunity and I kicked myself
for missing you're you're much better
off never realizing it until the game
the game is finished yeah and uh those
are the like ones where where you you
make a mistake and then people will tell
you after the game and you will feel
completely rotten but yes it's much much
better than actually figuring it out for
yourself and still having to continue
the game because uh you you do want to
uh the self loathing was strong with him
that day as the quote goes yeah that is
a feeling I'm very very well acquainted
with black if could go for the G5 break
right now I guess but I think it's
probably playing to lose more than
playing to win I don't know if Jeffrey
feels that he is sort of confident to uh
start taking risks against 13 seconds on
uh on Race clock here Tanya I've got to
ask you the same question do are you
affected does it impact your mindset
when you make a move and then you're
very happy with the move you made and
suddenly this awareness comes over that
you missed a winning moment 100% I think
every chess player has been through that
and uh I I completely agree that it's
better to not know if you don't have any
idea during the game you know you can
keep your mind be present in the moment
but it's so hard to let go of what has
just happened or what you've just missed
and in a format like this where you've
got another game coming up it's probably
even better to not know after the game
right so that you don't think about it
uh the moves that we're seeing been been
played over the last uh last couple of
moves there are no breaks possible
anymore on the was on the queen side
once uh Jeffrey played the move A4 which
was met by the way by the move A3 which
means that you're not playing B3 you're
not going to get C4 there's no way this
exchange is going to be impactful and I
think black has secured equality now to
me answer the move A3 feels like a
silent draw offer he's saying I'm on the
defense now I don't have I kind of feel
that yeah I get that and by the way I
love What Jeffrey has done he's played
Rook A8 Rook A5 and he's going to play
Rook B5 and by the way that's a that's a
tender Pawn on B2 it's a soft Pawn yeah
which requires this
ugly defense and at what point Peter do
you start
saying well if you're going to give me
the advantage I'm going to play honestly
once A4 once the sequence where black
played A4 and that was met by A3
happened I think only black really can
play for a win anymore because white
white is completely stuck there there
will never be anything that you can do
really to your position unless black
that does something dramatically stupid
and for black you can play Rook B3 and
then try to open something up on the
queen side you can maybe try preparing
the C5 break although that is very
double-edged if you do play C5 and it
doesn't come off for you immediately
that might actually signal yeah signal
once again that white has some winning
chances but generally I think uh Jeffrey
will feel like he's definitely the side
playing for a win here exactly by the
way Knight takes E4 is a move I would
Embrace as black D5 takes E4 and I'm
going to reroute my knight to the D5
Square that's why we saw Knight F3 by
Ray and okay are we going to see
repetition at this point because it also
feels like black has done maximum out of
the position that you can hope for your
Knights are beautifully placed in the
center The Rook is on the B file but
what's next to the only break that comes
to mind is the one that you pointed out
with C5 but that's a double Ed sword and
uh you create open lines and a D5
weakness in that case by the way Knight
E one I kind of like what Ray did
somehow this Rook came all the way back
and the Knight on
D3 is well placed it it kind of releases
our Rook for TAS thank
you uh yeah well you got me on that one
but the fact that the Rook which was
Maxim on Max maximized on D3 has gone
all the way back to A8 is an indication
that a draw is getting increasingly more
likely
Peter yeah on the other hand it feels
like black is really risking nothing at
all in the 402 it's now down to 20 but
there was at some point maybe even a
50-second difference on the clock will
perhaps work as a bit of an incentive
for for Jeffrey to continue even though
you are probably continuing by just
shuffling and not really committing to
uh to anything the only thing to commit
to would be something like B6 C5 but I
don't know if that does anything at all
yeah and with this Rook moving from one
side of the board to the other uh
Jeffrey is always threatening this move
G5 but it has to be timed correctly mhm
because you're doing white a solid favor
of opening up the H file potentially and
I think the move Rook G8 and A8 is a
silent draw for with the move Knight E1
but of course Ray says I'll play
on Knight C5 wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute B5 played so he defends
the B Pawn by moving it Forward also
defending the a pawn Rook yeah but now
there really aren't any breaks left
Knight C5 and B5 and then white goes
back with the Knight and the whole point
is that black doesn't have any breaks as
well on the queen side anymore right I
was about to say the move Knight C5 did
offer the potential for a knight trade
there Knight takes C5 and Rook to A5 I'm
a pawn grubber I at least uh thought
about the question 100% but then you
give this open E line for the White's
Rook to come into play and you can grab
a pawn but what white really wants is
Rook activity that Knight on e4 is so
much worth a more than a
pawn oh I forget who I'm with right now
need to watch my
words uh is worth so much more than a
pond boy I don't know I that's uh maybe
I should say what it depends which Pond
really we're talking about okay right
okay I'm going to I'm going to rephrase
myself give me a little Solace there
okay night uh Peter I'm I'm just seeing
the P the players kind of shuffling
they've they've kind of checked each
other's uh resumés out here pretty
solidly it feels like
uh any break here would be severely
detrimental to the side making the break
apart from maybe G5 but now that the
pawn on C6 is somewhat vulnerable I
think it's much harder for black to
abandon the uh the C8 Square for for The
Rook yeah feels like we are now perhaps
repeating exactly uh so far Tanya the
times have not been too much of a factor
I think Ray got under 10 seconds at one
particular moment but they're keeping a
Brisk Pace I'd say yeah yes uh and I
really feel that draw would be sort of a
fair outcome of this endgame play that
we've been seeing by these players is
difficult to imagine a break and as we
mentioned earlier Jeffrey's just
maximized everything in the position the
only thing that white shouldn't do is
trade on e4 right as you pointed out
then black just takes with a d pawn and
Vates that square for the Knight to jump
into
exactly so uh these Rooks are felt like
a moment ago there was an actual
repetition on offer with night before
perhaps rake would have even claimed
right a threefold and he goes Knight C5
instead preserving the the illusion that
something might still happen in this
game but I'm not sure I believe that the
more they play the more I feel we're
going to see G5 on the board at some
point Point really yeah I mean if there
was a time for G5 I would have said 5
seconds he needs to make a move
three and Rook H1 again panicky a little
panicky and honestly it's it's sort of
very inviting now against against 12
seconds because there might be some
there might be some uncomfortable
decisions to be made you you you start
encouraging or if if you're going to
encourage your opponent too much and
allow them to play G5 well one no
doesn't do
it uh I think it wasn't working for a
very precise specific reason and I think
Jeffrey I think if you play G5 takes
takes Knight D7 check was very annoying
that was the one yeah and then if the
King goes to E6 you have Rook takes E4
and that position might end up being not
that great for for black gotcha that was
just on my analysis board everybody I'm
going to uh refresh my board and come
back to the life position and it feels
like that could be a bit of a repetition
with Rook H1
now seen it a few times yeah what are
the players even playing for right now
it's so hard to tell cuz they're not
repeating the moves they are shuffling
around this is this is an interesting
point by the way 92 check has been
played as we can see on the screen not
on the live board and if if the King
goes forward G5 check might be very
strong and if King G2 even here I
thought G5 may have been playable but
King G2 G5 he sharks from it yeah and
goes back to C4 and again uh that sudden
attack on the G3 Pawn does look inviting
but I think you said it very well Peter
that the player who
um it's a blockade the player who lifts
the blockade who who makes the the break
yeah he the one in the receiving on yeah
he ends up uh getting injured by making
the break so they're just keeping
they're keeping the status quo here with
Knight F4 and King F3 or Rook H3 that's
not a square is not a square I would I
would have guessed it's Rook H3 yeah
what is it doing there I don't I don't
you know that maybe that's the ultimate
troll that I can put my Rook on H3 and
you still can't do anything you start to
think about Knight B2 and Knight takes
C3 because it's s of like so he wants he
wants the King
on he wanted the King on C1 maybe so he
he protected the G3 Pawn with the rook
and he wanted to start running with the
King to toward C1 C2 but I think but
then King E1 Knight F3 is the yeah
didn't quite work out for him yeah one
another seemingly draw is on the board
now once again yeah and Rook H3 is comes
back I think the the ultimate mysterious
Rook move very much in contention for
one of the more mysterious Rook Moves In
in chess history right and again I I it
always tickles My Funny Bone whenever I
think about this I make a move like Rook
H3 and I explain to Bent Larson that the
idea was to be able to play King to F1
to E1 to C1 and making this compelling
argument he looks at me and he says Yas
sir nobody believes
you just immediately shuts me down yeah
nobody believes
you I'm also not believing in Black's
chances currently it looks really nice
and uh a rep he might Wi on time though
because yeah he's playing Ray keeps on
leaving himself like 3 two seconds
habitually by the way a big shout out to
both Leos pores and bent Larson bent no
longer with us but lios still happily
kicking in Budapest as those two uh
great Legends uh join in the World Chess
Hall of Fame uh being inducted last
night very nice occasion uh uh along
with Susan
pogar our bell
ringer the round
absolutely and we're seeing uh the
shuffle around to continue and this
might just be the end of it now well I
think the players actually have to say
with my move G8 I am he's cling he's
claiming a draw it's
claiming uh and it's it's a kind of a
risky claim because I don't think you
can actually keep track how many times
or not yeah but it kind of gives them
the chance to maybe take a breather yeah
you get your opponent a minute big de
deal I mean that's the penalty if your
claim is disallowed the amount of times
you see in this position feels like a
like a reasonable guess it's got a good
shot and that's it handshakes he got it
right you got it right very impressed
honestly because I don't think I would
have been able to confidently stay that
I've seen this three times before me
either uh not with confidence but that
does up uh two draws three decisive
games and a couple of these decisive Gam
games I did not expect could you show me
where Wesley and Liam we didn't get a
chance to see that what happened yeah
that went down down downhill very very
quickly for for Wesley we left it not
here exactly we just saw move A5 we saw
the move A5 and we thought okay you know
Wesley is getting something yeah and he
played B4 and then took with a bishop
which I think is logical I don't think
he absolutely needed already to commit
to before but it's a logical decision 95
uh somewhere here I thought this is a
very balanced position and black should
maybe even be slightly better with the
Knight coming to D6 but okay takes takes
kn9 D2
and I assume something is wrong with the
mo move Knight D6 which I think I would
have made without thinking even it's not
suggested by the engine either and
Wesley played Queen B6 the Knight came
back to F3 which is arguably maybe draw
offer and then he did play 96 next move
96 Knight E4 and yeah I think maybe he
went for a little bit too much I think
if the knights come off here it should
be very very close to equality but okay
instead he played Queen G6 allowed
Knight C5 Knight
D7 uhoh uhoh I'm beginning to feel a
little bit uh yeah whoops good how do I
how did I get how did I get here and how
do I hit your menu there you go Bravo
hang on yeah we will we will get to
where we need to get to eventually hey
it's day one we're working out all the
Kings and then and then somehow the dewn
just just ran right from from here but
here are our standing yes yes well round
one we've had three decisive games two
draws and this is where we stand Ali
Resa with a fantastic win over Fabiano
Carana he did it with the black pieces
yes he did with two points for a win
along with Liam and Sam savian we had
two draws which put Maxim Anish Jeffrey
and Ray Robson with one point and at the
bottom of the board after round one the
first round loss Fabby Yan and a Wesley
wow three big Heavy Hitters there at the
bottom of the table goes to show you how
strong is our event as we get ready for
a break we uh check in with our friends
at Q Boutique and see what they have
well this is St Louis chess club it's a
puffy vest gear up in the newest apparel
from the St Louis chess club with the
officially branded puffy vest features
the chess club signature logo across the
left breast pocket 100% polyester stay
warm in style available at cutique
stl.com and as we go on our break
Anastasia caught up with Jeffrey Jong
hope you like her
[Music]
interview to
start so welcome to GR tour Jeffrey it's
not your first tournament in granch tour
that you participating you were here
last year uh do you think somehow it
helps you the fact that you have played
this already and you feel more confident
this year oh for sure because it's very
intimidating playing with these guys so
to get that experience makes it um more
comfortable and I think this is my third
time so hopefully third time is the
charm yeah you just actually come in
from Grand Swiss tournament which was in
N men and um how can you assess your
participation there how was the
tournament for you it was a very nice uh
venue but unfortunately my play was not
so nice um but it's still a very good
experience what did go
wrong uh I think at the beginning I made
a few too many draws and then started to
become a bit
frustrating um and then sort of took too
many R later on um I a professional
chess player right I mean these days and
um can you tell us a little bit how the
life of the professional chess player
looks like what is your routine what are
you doing every day how many hours per
day do you prepare for the games yeah so
I think on on average it's about 4 to 6
hours for me uh that's how much I work
and for this event I mainly did some
general preparation so got some some of
the openings that I plan to play in
order and some middle games and end
games as well yeah but in general I mean
you wake up and you start Starling chess
immediately or let's say what what is
the best schedule you can have as a
professional player uh do you work with
a coach uh no coach at the moment but
yeah okay I guess I wake up and usually
I do some physical exercise first in the
morning just to wake up a bit and then
then I get into some chess and it's sort
of um you know work on chess take a
break and maybe eat something then
exercise some more and then go back to
chess yeah uh what are your other
interest interests Hobbies I'm a big
sports fan so I play a lot of sports I
watch a lot of sports what are your
short terms and the long-term goals um
in your chess career uh shortterm
probably returning to 2700 would be my
first step um right now I dropped quite
a bit so just to get back on track there
and long term I think we'll see right
now I'm just playing uh to enjoy way and
hopefully if I can climb the ranks that
would be nice yeah and uh actually I
noticed in the video you sent us before
the chest tournament I've noticed uh
lots of books on the background I just
was wondering if you have read all of
them or some of them and what what is
your favorite yeah I can't say that's
that was my uh room I was actually
filming it uh in my parents room so my
dad is a very big reader I also have a
big bookshelf but I don't read quite as
many books I would say
um one of my favorite books that I read
though is the is a classic uh animal
farm so this is one of my favorites um
um who are some of your chess idols and
uh how they influenced your chess career
and your approach to the game um I have
a lot of Chess Idols I think an
underrated one for me like one that
doesn't get um said enough I think is
Vladimir karnick I really enjoyed his
his games um um when I was just before
grandmas I studied a lot of games and
that catapulted me from let's say 2450
to
2650 so I would definitely mention him
as one of the players that uh made an
impact yeah you also you are so lucky to
work personally with Gary casparo the
world champion you attended this school
for young talents and uh instant Lou
Club it was also organized here um so
what was um this unique experience you
had you know working with scar yeah it
was truly amazing just to get a chance
to um be around him in person and yeah
we worked many years I think maybe six
or seven years together um I could show
him my games and he would comment on
them yeah it was really really nice and
I think a lot of players benefited
greatly from that experience thank you
so much and all the best of luck for you
in the tournament thank you
the 2023 Grand chess tour reaches its
epic conclusion with its fifth world
class event the 2023 sinkfield cup it's
back to classical chess with Front
Runners settling in for the final push
to the Finish Line however two of
America's Finest stand in their way
joining the frey as wild cards who will
try to cash in on the opportunity while
making things as difficult as possible
for hopeful tour players who can win the
illustrious cup and will it be enough
for them to emerge as the 2023 Grand
chess tour Champion follow the St Louis
chess club's twitch and YouTube channels
to tune in to live coverage of the 2023
sinkfield cup November 21st to December
1st to find
out hello I'm women's Grand Master viim
janova I will be creating content for
Grand grest store follow us on social
media and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 15500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldes h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting St Louis chess
club.org
education
[Music]
hello welcome back everyone round two of
game one is about to start and what a
start we've had three decisive games
fireworks on the board and this is where
we stand going into game two ala Liam
Sam savan scoring a first round Victory
convincing games throughout Maxim anise
Jeffrey and Robson their games ended in
a draw while Fabby Yan and Wesley are
looking to score their first points
Heavy Hitters at the bottom there but
tell us about the pairings for this
round too and we will see the action
that's about to come up as Wesley so
plays against Sam Sean Wesley had a good
game in game one but it all ended very
abruptly from him he lost he's got to
bring that form back Yan naam Nishi
plays Anish giri he Jeffrey Jeong
against Ali Resa F Ali RAR looks like
he's really in form and in shape Robson
against Liam and Maxim vasher lra plays
Fabiano Karana action has started
exactly and Peter uh we're actually
coming in a little bit late I see a
dozen moves in the game between mvl and
Faby but what caught your
attention there's a a bunch of open
games uh the E4 E5 games on on the
boards there which I think is always a
welcome sign because those tend to be uh
quite uh quite fighting and another a
goes in similar to that game between uh
Liam and and Wesley in round one in the
game between Jeffrey Shong and Ali Resa
uh an sort of quiet looking Italian
there between in the game between Robson
and uh uh
Liam an interesting and very fastpaced
in terms of moves made by by me spent
game between uh Yan pomnish and Anish
giri and uh in in Wesley against Sam
savian arguably maybe the sharpest
position potentially uh we see so far
because these lines where white plays uh
Bishop G5 fairly uh they tend to they
they tend to be how do I how do I always
get that what did you do I did something
very stupid we and we've got five very
exciting matchups and before we Deep
dive into it Yas I want to ask you which
one stands out to you which one uh is I
thought the the game between mvl and
Fabby was fascinating because of this
particular move order so we get this I
mean come on the ruy Lopez it's the
single most oldest most what you talking
about I haven't seen this position
before ever ever H2 H3 and suddenly you
know you get Bishop E6 and this is like
an old move that somehow got lost in
fashion Peter but they used to play it
ages and ages ago and I think everybody
forgot how to get an advantage against
it yeah I think it makes a a great deal
of sense to just will something like
this out every now and again because
people will just be so confused like CU
nobody has seen this in in in decades
right and uh it's not great uh you you
have to start by saying that objectively
it's maybe not the the funnest position
you can get with black out of the
opening even though as you can see now
it
it's perfectly playable and it doesn't
seem to be all that bad right but uh I
think the main value in playing
something like Bishop B6 surprise is is
you do it once in that one game your
opponent will really have very very
little clue what he's supposed to do
against it and then you don't repeat it
for 5 Years everybody will prepare and
just as everybody thinks okay this will
never happen again you do it again right
that's that's the Strat I think there
you go I'm also extremely surprised that
Faby hasn't gone for his archangels in
this uh in this opening it's a cost that
he's just come out with exactly a very
extensive course uh but he decides not
to start with move Bishop to C5 right
which is the Archangel variation you can
go with B5 and then Bishop C5 or start
with Bishop C5 this is what his course
is on but he chooses another approach de
go for Bishop D7 and Fin's got to
Champion his cause you know right
exactly I mean it it's a bad sign when
you're the author of A course and then
you don't pick up uh the line your champ
name Peter what do you think do the top
players uh the very best in the world do
they actually study the courses that
their colleagues come out with just to
get an Insight I think it was a shock to
me when when I realized that very very
strong players actually are aware of
what I'm saying in my courses and yes uh
and it also creates this weird dynamic
where I know I trusted what I said in my
greenfeld course I I know like there are
mistakes there it's impossible to record
them this amount of material without any
mistakes at all but even judging by
feedback there hasn't been any real
glaring horrible horrible blunders in
there there have been stuff missed but
it's so it's not that you you lied and
you're never playing it because you know
that you lied and things aren't true but
you still don't want to give this huge
Target F to prepare for for you so it's
it's a kind of a weird mixture in
particular for somebody like me who it's
my main opening like for fa not to play
the Archangel I think is is easier than
for me to just suddenly stop playing the
gr field all together right it's it's
understandable that he doesn't really
want to give people uh the the
opportunity uh to Target him uh but as
we uh go through the MBL and we are have
caught up with the players you know
somehow Black's kind of landed on his
feet here I don't see too much going on
for white black is going to play Knight
D7 and if you told me this was a
Sicilian Defense that's say okay and if
black ever were to play Knight D7 and
maybe on a good day get in the move D5
that's it any opening
Advantage yeah it's gone absolutely I I
think it's all about this D5 square that
you're pointing out in these structures
if black gets a successful break on D5
you've done really good and white has to
do everything to fight that one of the
ways to fight it is to get rid of the
Knight on F6 so what why would have
really wanted to do is go Bishop G5 grab
that Knight which controls the D5 square
but that's been stopped by Fabby uh
before it even got started you know uh
yeah you what is it it's sort of like
good players solve problems great
players avoid them all together oh nice
o yeah but H6 I like it uh no advantage
and let's just take a a gander the
lifetime uh Advantage uh lifetime score
between uh these two players head tohe
here we go oh wow they've played against
each other a bunch of times even in rid
chess and I wouldn't have guessed this
either 22 to2 that's a decisive 2:1
Advantage for mvl huge advantage to m in
their head tohe but Maxim he's also the
former World Blitz Champion uh so he's
quite the Beast to face in these formats
we saw the big save he had in round one
against Anish as well finds those
Resources with little time on the clock
and this time it feels as if Fab's the
one who's managed to get a bit ahead uh
on that 17th piece which is a clock in
chess as uh we uh look at this again I
think that Fabby is doing fine uh take
it away Peter where do you see
advantages uh I don't see it in the MV
game how is nepo and Anish Gary to uh
big let's take a look big
players uh let's take a look and yeah
this one is is a quieter uh quieter uh
Affair Affair in in Italian where uh
once again and we see the the very very
heavily discussed Joo piano and Yan goes
for this A4 A5 Advance which is A4 has
become a very very standard thing to to
do in all of these types of positions A4
followed by the immediate A5 I think
less so uh and uh Anish responds by very
concretely he says now you've given me a
Target I will use this opportunity to
just offload offload some pieces off the
board and then some normal development
happened and this this is a very clever
Thing by andish there uh White you know
claimed some space advantage on the
queen Side by establishing a beach head
on uh on A5 and it gets immediately
challenged uh and once white commits to
B4 as well black is now ready to uh sort
of fight chain against chain white has
this very very beautiful long Pawn chain
but so is black and I think black should
just be uh reasonably comfortable maybe
it's a little bit as you can see uh on
the screen here a little bit preferable
for white due to
the slightly more space on the board but
it shouldn't be anything dramatic I
wouldn't think Tanya I have to laugh at
this I mean when I grew up with the Joko
piano I was playing C3 B4 A4 I wasn't
playing A5 A4 A5 in order to play C3 B4
uh very unusual approach but
balanced but yes when you said I'm going
to laugh at this I thought it was going
to be your question about wait a second
you're saying it's all balanced but
there's a point that there is that black
can actually win on this position
directly yeah but E5 takes D4 c c takes
what's going on here well I've got this
queen B3 Knight C4 kind of currently A5
is hanging so what what you start with
actually is you play A5 A6 making sure
that this PA on4 cannot be connected to
it's isolated yeah any other pieces and
then you pick it up by playing either
Queen B3 or perhaps Queen if Bishop B6
right we can start by Queen A4 and then
D4 D5 will come so this is a very
committal choice and I'm not sure it's
such a great choice for black to be
honest once you realize A5 A6 exists
because without I think the move A5 A6
black would snap at this because so you
just you want a Pawn on the queen side
you are threatening to take the second
one if a B6 Queen B6 happens black is
instantly and even this apparently is
somehow but Anish spots it he says uh A6
not allowing any of that keeps the
tension as is with this uh very unusual
Pawn structure on the board and makes
the move Queen to
C7 I was about to say are we playing
Queen to E7 or queen to C7 and I thought
it was commentator's choice and I wasn't
sure I think considering that white
maybe if if we talk about threats here
for white the move Knight C4 is maybe
the one thing yeah the one thing that
looks like a threat right and it
obviously attacks the pawn on D6 but if
you if you put your Queen on E7 you can
make an argument that B6 is also maybe a
bit vulnerable after KN C4 and you you
have to invest some uh some thought into
how you're protecting it because I think
once again maybe it doesn't work but I
spotted this very nice little tactic
here with Knight takes D6 and then D
takes E5 and suddenly you can see that
oh with so many pieces hanging uh black
actually does lose mat finish the line
you got I think we should finish that
line because black can actually trade
the Queen but it finishes with the Rook
jumping in and the bishop on D7 is
hanging the bishop on D7 is hanging your
knight is hanging and there's no way to
to connect anything so you are in a in a
lot of trouble here for black mat yeah
so Queen C7 preferred if you play Knight
C4 here you're not hitting anything yeah
you're not hitting anything I mean
Knight takes G6 might actually still be
a threat but you compared to the
previous line your B6 Pawn is not
hanging giving you a Tempo to do
something productive with your life yeah
Bishop E6 something a move a move of
some description yeah right Bishop which
is why Yan for now prefers not to commit
to Knight C4 either goes Queen
B3 it's it's going to be a very
interesting positional struggle where um
concrete calculations are not really
they come in sometimes but generally
people will be fighting on more
conceptual ground you know where do you
put your pieces which pieces you want to
trade and so on I want to say that uh
for me nepo has played quickly as you
mentioned earlier in round one I mean
he's played entire games with extra
moves on on his clock but yeah he's only
used two and a half minutes to get
himself you know deep into this uh
theoretical dispute I should say and so
probably I think they're on their own
how much is prep do you think Bishop
bfor I Bishop probably was noted as an
option but wasn't pay too much attention
to because it's not going to be a
reputation of anything it's just a game
and and these days I think particular at
the level that we are watching in this
tournament these are all elite
players uh the evaluation that is just
I'm going to get the game here it will
not be a forest draw which is great is
perfectly acceptable for most people I
gotcha uh and uh uh I I think that's
that's how it happened all right let's
go around the horn and just take a look
we're going to check in on the game
between Wesley so and Sam Sean Sam uh
very impressively defeated uh twice
Challenger uh y Bishop F6 yes and Rook
E6 and queen G6 and it was a Splat and
he's up against Wesley who actually lost
his first round and this looks like a
scotch no it's not a scotch excuse me so
this is a well hold on I think this is
the Archangel wait a not not really I
think I think
it's more of
a when white plays 5d3 I think white is
just saying you might play the open
Spanish and I don't want you to right
yes I think I think this is how we get
there and then yes it's a archangel's
key in in in spirit but the the
important distinction is that white I
think generally would like to play D3 on
the next move wait for black to develop
the bishop on to E7 and then play D3 but
that allows the open and people often uh
do this specifically against players who
might play the open okay and yeah if we
quickly get to uh where they got to uh B
G5 and uh for me this move D3
D4 it's a bit of a surprise it's unusual
yeah uh in particular when it's
connected so clearly with a loss of
temper because we've just played D3 and
then we play4 in the next move but they
do this sometimes and what I wanted to
say is this this reminds me very uh
dramatically of uh the the One Moment In
The World Cup where Magnus almost went V
the wide game against Vincent kimer
which had this structure I even scrolled
through the game a little bit thinking
maybe they actually repeating the game
between M and Vincent and have only just
departed it but no it was similar but
not this move order uh but yeah this is
the the moment where once Vinson didn't
find that combo yeah which I think would
have effectively knocked Magnus out of
the tournament you felt that now that
that H hasn't happened Magnus probably
is winning the tournament some Destiny
yeah he generally doesn't give people
too many chances to to do well against
him in knockout events exactly um I
noticed that uh after the move Queen D3
or maybe even before the move Queen D3
uh your uh games disappeared so we're no
novel very new uh I think this is still
no actually maybe it's up to here yeah
up to up to Bish P 46 you even you even
get some some very strong games there
was some game by by aradi nidage going
further down but then I think it
disappeared period yeah so this is all
reasonably Uncharted Territory and how
are they doing Peter in terms of
evaluation the engine gives white a
slight plus but I don't think it's much
uh and
um I think normally it should be it
should be around equal i' I've already
started looking uh at this tactic but
currently it doesn't work because Queen
takes G7 exists I'm pretty sure is also
Bishop D d8 C7 wins but even even this
is very strong but you can start in the
current position by
castling and
then which which side would you like to
Castle Queen side yeah I think I think
the the the attractive the attractive
ambitious option here is to Castle Queen
side but the issue is I think after
Bishop takes C3 you will have to take
with the pawn o because Queen C3 R takes
because this this now should work
question mark yeah favorably for yes
because you take on C3 and you hit the
Rook on D1 that's it's still it's still
sort of playable for white but you're
not going to be uh like there will be
some compensation for the exchange
because he will pick up the pawn on D6
but obviously Nobody Does this to play
for a win it's just it's just that
you're not lost which is a good thing
but not a great thing so you will have
to take with the pawn and having Castle
quein side having to immediately
recapture with the pawn on C3 is not a
particularly attractive proposition
although it's not unplayable and if that
forces white to Castle King side then uh
uh the position is quite balanced and
you can also still go for this this line
as well but at least your king is safer
on the king side well as a commentator I
would love to see Queens side castling
it just means more fun for us but
probably if you're playing uh Queen side
castling could be extremely dangerous in
this position we'll see how this one
develops yes and I see another game has
CAU your attention exactly well I mean I
told you uh prior to the start of the
tournament that Ali raaza was going to
win the event so let's see how our
tournament winner is
doing uh Queen A4 check Knight C6 E3 and
uh Jeffrey is uh playing I want to say
an incredibly fashionable line that
somehow Bishop D2 and these rosans I
don't know how it became so popular but
I'm seeing Wesley so and some
really strong strong theoretical players
playing like this and it's like a slow
play Peter but it's all about just
trying to get a playable position yeah
it's a it's a weird kind of a dance uh
in particular if you play Queen A4 and
then you don't play Knight E5
immediately and allow black to Castle
safely uh then you you you get to this
stage of the game it doesn't happen
every time and I think in the game
between uh Le and Wesley uh it actually
became very concrete quite quickly but
what we're watching here is another
thing that happens quite a bit in this
line where shuffling now there is this
weird sequence where everything is sort
of revolving around black wanting to
take on C4 but wanting to do it in such
a way that white will have to spend two
Tempe to recapture okay and white also
has a bunch of waiting moves before
white decides to go BB2 Bishop D3 so
black goes Bishop f8 we play Rook D1
Black Goes H A6 we play Bishop D2 C1
because why not because we have so much
time but coaches around the world right
now are having heart attacks because
they've been teaching children for
generations to develop your pieces get
your king into safety don't move the
same piece twice in the open thank you
oh you went to school I'm impressed on
you and you're playing Rook D1 and
Bishop back to C1 these coaches are
saying it's still it's still
understandable because once again we're
expecting DC4 to happen eventually and
then having The Rook on D1 having that
Rook on already control the defile with
not without the bishop on getting in the
way I think my perfect sense and also
Peter were you often in these positions
where white really wants this bishop is
on the B2 Square in some so once you've
kept it back on C1 taken out your Rook
you're already eyeing B4 Bishop B2 long
term you're trying to convince the kids
of the world to move their pieces three
times first put your Bishop on D2 then
put it back on C1 and then put it to its
rightful Square B2 Tanya chess has
changed the computer is your new chess
course is going to be fabulous I can
tell you okay Bishop E2 at last now we
come to an interesting spot because
happen DC4 Queen C4 and a very concrete
response here by lza he goes B7 B5 which
looks like a blunder of a full piece but
it actually is just a draw offer because
if you take on C6 we will play Bishop D7
Queen B7 we will play Rook B8 oops not
Queen B6 of course but Queen A6 Rook A8
and white could pretend and I don't know
take on a take on B5 but that probably
is trying to lose more than trying to
win so what the game actually ends with
is a repe is this repetition so uh for
Jeffrey here it's a pretty clear-cut
choice you can play Queen to any Square
you can go probably D3 is the most
natural maybe you can make some argument
for B3 and then the game will continue
or you take on C6 and you say I've won I
I have to tell you guys I played enough
simultaneous ism my life that when my
opponent plays the move B5 I would say
to my would you like it back would
please you're just
blundering would you like it wrong this
is extremely concrete though right
because if you go back to D3 he might
even be thinking about going B4 all
those Bishop moves that you were talking
about yeah sir that white has made uh
you still have an Castle your king is in
the center or or E5 even yeah or E5 B4
E5 two very tempting options if you go
back with the queen to B3 at some point
you've also got Knight to A5 Bishop B7
ideas jumping in uh and I'm just
wondering if the fact that Jeffrey has
slowed down does he feel that perhaps
taking a repetition is a safe ba
outa I don't think he is better if he
doesn't so the question is how how
ambitious he feels very early in the
tournament he's playing against somebody
who will just be yeah on on very very
little
current evidence but unlike lifetime
evidence who will be one of the
favorites of the event uh he's had a
very solid game in round one and I think
if if he felt he has a decent shot of an
advantage if he doesn't take one six he
would continue I think he is generally a
very ambitious young man but if you're
continuing just to continue against ala
and ala is playing quite quickly clearly
knows what he's doing here uh I'd like
to see that because I honestly I feel
that for for like the experience of
playing
as many games againsta as possible is
going to stand you in very good stad
eventually exactly but from a purely
chess point of view I don't think he can
be faulted here by taking on C6 and
saying okay let's play one more game and
uh prepare for dayto what would you do I
was actually going to throw the ball to
you as the body language expert in the
house yes first you look at Jeffrey
right now yeah does he want to continue
at this game or is he going to grabb on
C6 I think you take on C6 unless your
preparation is such that you you you
have worked out that Queen D3 the
Retreats Queen D3 Queen B3 give you
something concrete Advantage but I don't
see it I really don't I mean if you go
Queen D3 and black gets an
E5 I'm not enthusiastic I'm and honestly
if if we continue this line a bit
further let's say we take on E5 and then
all the TR D3 I guess I take with the
Rook what am I whichever whichever one
you choose yeah Knight Tak 95 kn95
rookie 5 and we stop there and we
discuss this position for a second I
think this end game is potentially
better for black correct if anyone is
better here long term it's black y so
this is what I mean he's taken too much
time he's going to grab the Knight if
you want to continue playing you make
this decision within the first minute or
two you don't spend that much time here
one of my favorite stories I was playing
against John Fedor witz in it's one of
those moments where I make a draw offer
and John thinks for 15 minutes so I
think he's not going to take the draw
but then he thinks for 30 minutes now
I'm absolutely certain he's going to
take the draw then he thinks for 45 and
when he doesn't take the draw offer I'm
so
grateful I me your your your window of
acceptance uh Peter uh gets did you flag
him eventually yeah won that I mean he
took 45 5 minutes it was like the Grid's
draw of all time you froze him in a deer
H you you take enough time and wrap it
10 minutes
think yeah at some point it becomes
completely impractical to continue as
well and precisely that was my point you
know you at a certain moment you're
going to take on C6 just because you're
down as a as a well established
unofficial member of the chicken chess
club I I also want to I also want to
point out that it's also a trick people
use to make sure that they accept the
draw right CU to take some time you
think you might actually have to
continue but you also know that if you
give yourself thoughts for like if you
think for enough time that you don't
have much time left you will be able to
tell yourself I couldn't continue I left
myself Justified yeah I left myself 10
minutes for 15 moves there is no way I
can continue from that's a that's a
really important Point especially in
this position because the game has just
started right now uh Queen to B3 or D3
and things just begin to happen you need
that time on the clock so the more he
think thinks now less time than Ali Resa
on the board uh it looks like Jeffrey is
eventually going to decide to take that
Knight on C6 and walk into the
repetition watching the the board view
alza was just he was the picture of
somebody who knows what's going to
happen and it's just like just take on
C6 already with this you've taken five
minutes already you take seven now
you're going to take the draw come on he
knows uh here at Webster University uh
coach Liam has uh he definitely yeah he
knows where we're going to see a draw
coach Liam of Webster University uh got
a win in round one and so he's
sporting uh a tie for first uh let's
just jump into his position with Ray
Robson and you know the position that
the players have achieved I just want to
say it has to be a theoretical draw uh
duel a theoretical duel I think that's
fair uh jump in and tell me what the
players are doing and what grandmas
games are they following Peter because I
don't know what's going on plenty if we
if we start from move seven here and
this is a very kind of a classical Joo
Jo piano where black I mean we were
taught to play A6 and Bishop A7 but more
and more these days you just play Bishop
B6 with the intention of playing Knight
D6 and then knight7 and then C6 and this
is what happens here H3 black
reroutes uh reroutes the the yeah and
once white goes Bishop E3 preparing to
go kn2 and consolidate completely black
immediately hits uh hits back in the
center trying to sort of resolve all the
issues we have here by playing D6 D5
okay and this is a very typical thing
that they do in these structures but it
normally doesn't lead to anything but
equality and black is shooting for
equality and not more but here after a
sequence of seemingly very logical play
Black uh you know white took a pawn and
a knight black took a pawn and the
Knight white took on G7 and black played
Rook E8 and suddenly you realize that
this is not so comfortable for white you
have to take some maybe unpleasant
decisions because the PA on G7 is there
but it's not really it's not doing very
much but black has much more pieces
aimed at the white king than than white
has so allowing F takes G2 is not going
to be very much fun and eventually uh
what Ray ended up doing is he took on G6
here had the option of including the
move let's say Bishop takes Bishop takes
H7 sorry about that how did I do that
you're doing good yeah and then Rook
takes D1 which maybe was better than
what he did uh but he went for something
which I think is very ambitious but
probably not that great instead of
Bishop H7 he took on D1 first and after
HG he made this move G2
G4 which is a way to preserve his
kingside
structure to a degree but maybe some
danger and then he wants to dig out this
Pawn on F3 I assume he just wants to
play KN bd2 almost immediately whatever
black does in responds but this is a
very high risk strategy because
obviously your king side is going to be
quite vulnerable and as you can see the
engine is also not uh in love with it
not enthusiastic right King takes G7
might something something that he may
have missed is this idea of yeah or
maybe even stronger is to start by
taking and then playing Rook h8 and this
entire complex on on the king side for
white is is crumbling because you you
can't really you would like to play King
H2 here but that compounds compounds
your
problems yeah no that's embarrassing uh
Tanya I have to admit when I see King G7
and Rook h8 I want nothing nothing to do
with this as white because I'm seeing uh
and I don't even want to play Bishop
takes B6 because I'm helping my opponent
to open up that AI line for the other
Rook the Side Pawn comes to the center
of the board and notice the clock here
he's under 3 minutes Ray Ray is in big
trouble he has to sort out the problems
on the board and he has to do them
really quickly while for black the moves
just slow right Rook to h8 is coming in
and we do have a draw as we were
predicting Jeffrey Jong decided to go
for the repetition but just to finish
your thought what you just were saying
about ra once again 3 minutes under few
minutes and a bad POS with the white
pieces you haven't yet finished your
development on the queen side this is a
disaster this is is an absolute disaster
for Ray uh to be worse with white after
18 moves and with three minutes on the
clock and I think he had to make the
move that he did with the King stepping
forward because otherwise you don't have
enough time once The Rook lands on the H
file because of the pin on H3 then
Bishop G4 would have been a threat so
King H2 played his idea is to get the
king to G3 the big question is is black
in time with penetrating The Rook to the
second rank yeah that's a
question deserves a very good answer uh
I'm not sure that Ray will have a good
answer by the way the move F5 also uh
becomes attractive uh rookie two
reaching out for it and he plays it yeah
Rook two looks very very logical of
course if two is being hit and uh as is
the on the queen side I think Ray is
intending to play N9 G2 uh King G3 okay
I think Knight G2 is is better using the
fact that if you take on F2 now King G3
actually equalizes because the Rook
cannot really stay on the second we will
take on F3 show away The Rook goes and
this this looks just to be very very
level so instead of Rook takes F2 it's
much stronger just to include one more
piece in the game play Bishop B6 okay
King G3 seems logical and for instance
you can play Rook d8 forcing white to
take on F3 not with the King but with
the Knight and now we take on D1 which
take on B2 and better it's very clear
that white is uh fighting for a draw
here you maybe make a draw if you play
very very precise Struggle No look at
the pawn structure yeah it's it's going
versus two on the clock it's going to be
very very unfun for for Ray here unfun
and that that not even considering how
far behind he is on the clock where he
he has 2 minutes against 21 and it's
only going to I think worsen for Liam
this is absolutely a dream come true W
it's his kind of position as well it's
strategic you're playing for two results
it feels like uh no complications you're
up on the clock and Robson with no ray
of light in his one exactly and uh with
the double points for winning in the
Rapids that you get uh Liam will just be
uh in Cruise mode uh let's go to the
game of MBL and Fabby and catch up on
these two players we left it around the
part of
H6 and our thinking was very
straightforward uh it was about the D5
square and whoever best controlled D5
and once BBY got in the move D6
D5 uh his troubles were more or less
behind him or not not not entirely I
think enely there is still a very fair
assessment of what's going on but with
with white having the more active rook
and also with the on A6 having to be
constantly watched you still I think
pick white here even though if you
imagine the same position but with let's
say The Rook on D7 if we go all the way
to the current position here if you
imagine this rook and this Rook being
gone off the board and the black king on
A6 wow Black is Black is very yeah yeah
black is much better and probably uh has
significant winning chances and if you
imagine all four Rooks coming off the
board it might just be dead lost for
right
uh so the evolation here is changeable
definitely black can improve and black
could at some point be very very
comfortable but for now I think the
bishop is trying to come out to E3 the
reason why made this slightly awkward
looking move G3 is that he didn't like
to think about where to put it after F4
yeah putting it on A7 is not really uh
such a dream Bishop C5 is playable but
he just decided to try to stop a four
altogether and black can deal with this
in a variety of ways you can just ignore
it I assume E7 is playable it's not it's
not the most glamorous move in the world
but it's playable or you can continue
insisting that A4 is something you want
to do you can play G5 I don't think I
don't think it's illogical to play G5
here so interesting endgame but
reasonably balanced I would say fair
assessment all right uh continuing our
uh look around uh where did I miss it
there it is it's a Anish and Yan when we
left it we had this queen C7 on the
board right boy the players I forget
that in Rapids they play rapidly B6 B5
uh before we get any deeper at Tanya B6
B5 first move come to your mind do you
like that move I don't know I have mixed
feelings about it it's clear that he
wants to put the C5 Pawn onto C4 and
kill that light Squad Bishop on F you
get that it's Justified but you are oh I
was about to say you are encouraging B4
takes C5 B takes C I thought he was
going to play let me just put this on
the board bcbc A6 we're talking about is
artificially isolating remember when we
allowed the pond to come to B4 and he
played A6 now it's a little bit
artificial I that's said yes if white
gets if black gets C4 in this position
that A6 Pawn which looks really
beautiful can also be a weakness in many
of the positions a Target here let's say
we go r r i I can see that spoken in one
voice there yeah uh and there was I I
want to show one specific position here
uh because I think Yan's reaction to B5
was very very interesting and probably
very good he took on C5 and played C3 C4
and and this is where uh it seems like
what we're trying to do here is just to
trade everything off but in fact it's
quite uncomfortable for black because if
you take C takes B4 why just goes going
to take C takes B5 and this is probably
a goner like this Pawn doesn't survive
and this looks like it might just be
lost and if you take this way your issue
is you will not be able to recapture
with he takes B4 because there is a pin
and if you play Rook C8 white goes B5
and once again you can't Eng says it's
playable but for for for my to my human
eye this looks very very dangerous and
there's also the move Rook ec1 which
might be even stronger right so uh Anish
played Rook B8 Yan played Rook e C1
Bishop B6 and here there was a very cute
moment where Yan played something which
I quite like from an aesthetic point of
view I think it's a very interesting
idea and he it might even pay off for
him eventually but he missed a very
beautiful idea here because he could
have played Queen A3 which I assume he
declined because of CB4 Queen takes B4
and B takes C4 however however
specifically after Queen A3 and it has
to be on this square and no other Square
after she takes B4 you take here you go
he takes B5 and you defend the Rook with
the queen yeah Queen takes C1 would have
won a full Rook if you had to recapture
this way if your queen was in yeah but
of course you don't because you can take
with you can take with this side so that
was an option which I think was quite
strong and if C takes before if we
dislike C takes before we end up having
maybe to make this move but then white
recaptures on C5 and it seems like the
pawn on C4 is going to get picked up
next move I'm Charmed yeah and a free
roll it's it's not as bad as all that
black can play Rook F C8 and actually
maybe with precise play doesn't lose but
it's it's a it's an opportunity border
line for sure Queen instead Yan went for
a very interesting idea he just gave up
a full reasonably healthy Pawn on the
queen side to do this to the black
structure okay and this is now a very
long-term compensation for for the pawn
given up I'm a pawn grubber but I like
the compensation yeah it's it's
definitely enough the question is
whether it's more than enough right and
a lot of moves were made here so let's
just briefly
show the current position so Yan triples
up on on the C file here and hang on a
second yeah why do
I yeah but seems like something
something quite bad happened here
because seems like big progress for
black we were enjoying this for white
and then see seems like there was a
miscalculation so this was still
fine grops how I
no no exit
where oh no I think I think you'll have
to do it from your side I'll tell you
I'll tell you what we'll jump to my
board and you tell me where you want me
to go Peter we just had this position
you tripled up so so takes takes
happened on B1 yes uh Knight A3 Rook B3
yes and here I think Knight B5 maybe was
still fine but Queen E1 or queen D2 is a
move that he played I think he just
missed C4 he missed C4 yeah I think C5
C4 was missed and the point is that you
can't take with the Rook cuz the Knight
on B5 is hanging and if you take with
the bishop what's the tactic
there Works Queen C5 check so Queen F2
runs into Rook B1 mhm Bishop F1 Queen
takes B5 Queen takes Knight oh that is
nasty that is very very nasty indeed uh
because you have to play Bishop to F1
and that walks into a self pin so the
move C4 oh nice very nice here and
another move that I want to point point
out which was very impressive by Anish
was this Knight Retreat to E8 and the
whole idea behind Knight E8 was to stop
the queen from coming on to C7 to trade
because it's very important for black to
keep that Queen defending that A7 and E6
weakness so knight8 a really nice
prophylactic move there by Anish giri
yeah just to keep the C7 Square
protected I mean you've got a Pawn on A6
and it's blockaded but if you ever
extract that A7 pound off the board game
over so Knight E8 necessary and queen D2
overlooking C4 I like this ouch uh is
this the current position it is yeah and
Yan is now faced with a very very
difficult Choice as you can see you can
play Bishop takes C4 and just give up
those two pieces for for the rook and
end up with a position which is clearly
better for black but also uh let's say
like you mean maybe maybe def yeah King
H1 and then just take on B5 after Rook
B5 right and so you get two
knights but you're also losing the A6
pawn more or L straight away because
Queen F1 mate is a bit of a threat
so yeah it's a it's a tough choice but
the issue is if you don't do that if you
let's say retreat with a KN back to C3
which is maybe the
the yeah black will play Knight D6 as as
advertised yeah and now you're sort of
worse everywhere where your Bishop on F1
has lost touch with the pawn on A6 black
Pawn on C5 progressed a very very
important one step further to C4 and is
well protected there and even your king
arguably is less safe than the black
king because you very much kind of
dislike having played F to F3 I I don't
disagree with any every anything you've
said uh Peter I and I don't mean to be
disagreeable but why doesn't he include
Queen C5
check because I think he values this not
being an En I think he doesn't want to
play allow Queen F2 yeah well King H1
Knight D6 has got to be considered an
improvement that's an improvement yeah
I'm pretty sure it's Queen F2
specifically want to play Queen D4 I
guess yeah that was the intention with
Queen F2 Queen D4 perhaps you can go
Knight E2 and force the queen to
actually trade on F2 and then C4 is
attacked yeah I think he wants to keep
the Queens on the board and he so
something like this and takes takes 96
and you have to start thinking
about6 though R B6 okay but he did he he
kept the Queens on the board rightfully
or wrongfully I'm not sure Knight D6 and
we're up to date are we up to date we
are yeah are and keeping the Queens on
the board another idea can be to go C7
get that Queen to B6 because as we've
been talking about this A6 Pawn which
can be a strength in a lot of position
has suddenly become a bit of a target
with that F1 Bishop losing connection uh
with that move C4 Fair absolutely by the
way I've always felt uh that Yan is one
of those I want to say streaky players
MH he gets on a
rampage you're in trouble he can he can
walk away with the tournament equally he
can go the other way and you know just
gift points away it feels like he's
losing a bit of control here today today
will not be his you will need to kind of
stop the bleeding in round three because
this one looks like it's headed the same
way the first one has gone uh it will be
very very difficult to hold this
position because and now yeah Knight A4
it did take under control to B6 square
but Peter as you were pointing out that
now this position gets dangerous cuz
there's a C6 Square which would hit the
A6 pawn and the Knight on A4 exactly the
Queen's helping black and eventually the
Knight on G6 which hasn't really been
doing very much for quite some time will
start coming in by4 D3 and so on and and
yeah it's just going to go downhill from
here it already feels like it's barely
defensible if if if at all defensible he
goes queen of two which is a clever move
trying to let's see how these two match
up in their head-to-head lifetime score
in Rapid of course and there we have it
wow they have played against each other
almost I'm trying to do the mental MTH
but it feels like almost 100 times in in
Rapid play I was about to say they can
do a Trilogy of books on their rapid
chess uh our best games and I bet you
they've been Fabulous by the way 24 wins
there for Yan we talked about Anish
being a very solid player you beat a
Nishi 24 games I don't care whether it's
a blitz or rapid that's I'm still more
impress impressed by the volume than
anything else that's 82 games in that
was better mental match than mine 82
games
a that is a lot of games 24 wins to Yana
pishi but it looks like Anish is a step
closer to trying to level that score
with this game know yeah uh but this
move Queen F2 was actually yeah this is
was a very decent move it's a knight C5
Knight C5 or even maybe Queen C5 on a
very very good day but Knight C5
specifically but it feels like Knight F4
is very strong now including your last
game your last piece which wasn't really
uh doing that much just just trying to
go KN of4 on G3 and F and after G3 do
you jump on to D3 and yeah we just go on
D3 take with the rook and it seems like
it's just bad for white or at least
that's what the engine is
suggesting and by the way
uh not surprisingly Rey uh who was down
on time has been playing on his
increment almost throughout T last time
we checked it was 20 minutes to Liam and
2 minutes to rson and he's been playing
the last few moves with just then with
just seconds on his clock and uh what's
the position how is that a down for
white yeah we thought it was very very
difficult to hold and that's still the
case pet still the case but he's
defending really really well in
particularly if you consider how how
little time he's had to to find good
Solutions uh Machin suggest this is
holdable Machin suggest this is within
within the the parameters for white to
make a draw and how confounding is that
because I was about to say don't we have
the connected past pawns from a human
perspective you look at this and it
feels like it should be a loss that
Bishop on C6 it feels like a monster
Bishop you've got these two connected
past pawns uh it's not going to be easy
to hold this position I'm just wondering
why white is not doesn't have a bigger
Advantage than what the the black
doesn't have a bigger Advantage than
what the I guess it's because we've got
King F4 and Knight F5 as counterplay
against the black king and maybe maybe
even on a good day H6 uh could be so
something like King F4 he needs to make
a move you five seconds keep king of you
know I sometimes really I just like it's
one of those you put your hand on your
face and you say I can't see I don't
want to look at Ray's Ray's clock King
F4 uh apparently a mistake but also a
move I probably would have made myself
and you I would agree entirely with what
you were saying and and what the engine
was suggesting instead which apparently
was completely equalizing is I think
just unplayable in a real game and that
was the engine was suggesting to play
Rook E5 provoke B6 and then put it back
on E7 oh be serious yeah nobody nobody
does that exactly just no and the idea
is that the bishop would then be
vulnerable to you were correctly
pointing out that this bishop on B6 is a
pride and joy of black position so solid
on on that C6 Square undermining it and
then attacking it was very strong and
now after King F6 followed by Rook H1
black is going to have back in business
very good winning chances in particular
against State second seven six uh he has
to play and he decides to put the Rook
on C7 so at least stopping the B Pawn
from moving forward and is he counting
on the Knight jumping to G4 and playing
H6 next yes probably yeah but Rook H1 is
very strong unfortunately for him you
can actually just put the Rook behind
allow the pawn to get to H6 let's say
you go Knight G4 check we go King E6
white goes H6 but there's no threat and
black can start running uh his own
passers just go C4 here and suddenly
with the Knight not on E3 C4 C3 C2 C1 is
a very very legitimate
problem issue yeah it happens very fast
it happens much faster than you would
have expected yeah not to suggest that
F7 F5 might also just kind of tease the
night uh things are looking very bad for
Ray uh he uh well he's playing on
increment so it's not a surprise and
that's the reason you wanted to provoke
or at least the engine wanted to provoke
the B Pawn to move to B6 because that
Bishop on C6 stops any uh lateral
defense from C7 stopping preventing that
C5 Pawn from moving forward might just
be as simple as pushing it once the
knight from E3 moves Away by the way we
have C5 C4 immediately uh not including
the move Rook H1 and I just saw that
Ray the clock with one second one second
i' i' I've witnessed this too often in
my life uh 1 second on the clock and
we're going to see that in uh that was
also also very very strong actually what
uh what Liam has done there and yeah H
played and H7 we can just go Rook H1 and
pick it up I was about to say uh a
moment ago we're getting the Rook behind
the pawn with Rook H1 now that the pawn
has made it all the way to C3 this looks
like it's lights out Rook H1 and I want
see that one second and through the
magic of Television Tanya let's do an
action replay and there
three and with a second on the clock and
one second on the clock oh oh he made it
easily e easily he he probably had like
half a second maybe even 710 of a second
there yeah the clock is
Nott
connoisseur you could see him pressing
the button as the as the digital was
changing from two to one so yeah I think
by his standards he made it very very
comfy comfy but it doesn't help the
position no it doesn't unfortunately for
him as uh we do have an update on the
position Rook came to H1 Knight dropped
back to E3 I think he just took the pawn
and allowed King E3 yes so are we up to
date yes after King E3 and now you can
play King E5 and uh that's a nice move
yeah and I think King D3 runs into check
and F5 which is probably very very
strong well indeed uh but if you don't
have King D3 you really have no sensible
moves here at all so two pawns down and
uh yeah I think that's uh Johnny ball
game uh what do you got for us in the uh
Anish garyi
position uh it's become a bit less clear
actually I think Yan is now in in decent
drawing chances territory because there
was a point after Queen F2 Knight F4 was
very strong but Anish went with Queen A5
and Rook B1 which is also quite strong
but in this position the engine was
suggesting uh quite drastic measures it
was suggesting you just give up your
your pride and joy your opponent C4 for
peace activity and it was suggesting
that after this move Rook B1 A1 the
threat of Rook A2 is so strong wow that
it starts giving up material it starts
playing Rook takes D4 and you even have
a choice of which material you want to
pick up because Rook A2 also exists but
instead Anish went with f8 a kind of a
passive move giving white time to to
play King G2 and now uh this is an
improvement oh massive Improvement yeah
this is still maybe not very pleasant to
play on low time but Jan is not really
this is a difference between let's say
what Yan is doing here and what Ray has
been doing because yan yan also had a
very Troublesome position with white but
he always kept the clock under control
and this is obviously just so much
easier to play with a very po Knight on
F safe safe King on G2 alha white you
are a on down but you I think you are
kind of f taking yourself to make a draw
here exactly I I I would betting on
yourself
draw very highly anisha's first game
against Maxim vasher gra completely in
control uh Advantage from the beginning
but then one in accuracy and your
opponent is back in the game Rook a one
and I think it comes down to that uh
Anish characteristic and correct me if
I'm wrong here Peter of trying to keep
things under control too much sometimes
this night of faith it felt like that I
was too cautious I think also if if we
once again if we return to this
spot you feel that your position is so
good that the thought of giving white
anything the thought of like parting
with your wonderful passer on C4 is just
so so upsetting that I recognize this
this desire to not give any counterplay
at all and try to win sort of on
autopilot try to win without really
calculating any variations anymore it
often actually lets you down very very
strongly because you you do at some
point need to go in need to commit to uh
finding the finishing blow right and
just to remind everybody as we're in
round two what the standings were
following round one Tanya do the honors
and this is where we are we're going to
have a lot of switch-ups after round two
as Al has already finished his game with
the draw but he started round two with a
win so uh start with a round one win at
two points along with Liam and Sam in
top three position and then from fourth
to eight we've got Maxim Anish Jeffrey
and Ray and of course the players are
still fighting it out and anything can
happen and we saw Yan pishi is back in
his game against Anish so he might be
able to hold this one but the Heavy
Hitters there at the bottom I just uh
Drew pulled up the game between mvl and
fabbi because it seems to me that uh mvl
from the position where we left it which
was right right about here G3 it seems
to me that mvl has done everything
perfectly like he's improved like if you
look at this position you're going to
see The Rook on A1 included the bishop
and the king and black has basically
done nothing okay so we're going to see
that in the next few little while that
white has really improved everything
right here the bishop went from C1 to C5
the D the Rooks have been doubled the
King has Pro come up and I think mvl has
really improved his position
dramatically well the my first take
Bishops have been traded off and uh it
still feels like things are under
control but White's Rook activity you
can tell is so much more and if white is
able to actually double up on the
seventh Rank and create some uh threats
along it but what Fab is perhaps relying
on is to move Rook to E7 you want to try
to trade off at least one pair of Rooks
here as black I don't know Peter this
sure feels like uh Fabby just let his
opponent achieve too much yeah it feels
like this is the absolute best uh
position you maybe could have had right
from the previous one that we discussed
a dream you you still you still have to
find a way to win this it might still be
holdable just because of just how solid
it is for black and just how difficult
it is to make progress I assume progress
is connected with plane B3 and C4 right
without that you don't really generate
anything he starts by playing Rook D5
which is a bit of a curious move maybe
he is actually just preparing for Rook e
7 making it slightly less comfortable
for black to play Rook e 7 because he
will not be able to take with the King
very nice with f five being being on pra
so a little bit of a prophylactic move
there Rook to D5 and then we could see
it followed up with B3 C4 or maybe even
Rook A7 at
some if you don't mind me being a little
bit of a a devil's advocate here and you
know I liked what you were saying uh
there Tanya you want to double up the
Rooks on the seventh rank this is a
massive maybe winning threat and if you
play Rook E7 and if I just I mean I'm go
ahead and
force this Rook ending I thought we take
with the King perhaps you if you will
yeah that that that's absolutely fine
and if I go Rook
here G6 and I go King D4 yeah the big
question is what what is this Pawn
ending like exactly that was my question
for you Peter uh I I would need to think
about it um I'm not sure you got 12 sec
13 10 and also in this particular
position maybe3 D6 King C5 looks very
scary no it does it does look like three
holds okay e33 followed by rookie 4
check Rook G4 might generate just enough
activity for for black to to escape okay
because that's another thing that you
you know about games you very often lose
them if you play passively but you do
hold them by and we have a lot of action
that's happen Let me refresh my board
because you're absolutely right a lot of
action and after the move Rook D5 I
think Fabby was uh smelling the bacon
and it was cooking and it was his bacon
and he played the move G5 and we do have
HG King takes G5 on the board and a few
moves HG King takes and Rook F7 you have
to go Rook
E5 Rook E5 okay or I'm
not not sure what's going on
here uh I'm with you on this one well
black is in trouble the question is
whether it's already too far or you can
still maybe defend if you play really
really well Rook F7 played by the way
yeah Rook e five the engine for some
reason also includes Rook G7 check here
yeah exactly I wanted to say that after
drives the king back and then goes rook
dd7 and it really hates the black
position now really really hates it this
well well this is where Tanya was saying
if you could double the Rooks on the
seventh Rank and now it's gorgeous and
every King Pawn ending will be lost now
right that's the point then you get to
go B3 and C4 and all the king and pawn
end games are lost so what we're talking
about is go ahead and trade the Rooks
checking on F4 and go You've Got King F4
but you've got B3 and C4 yes coming in
next and it's easy by the way Fabby has
made the move Rook to E5 so we might be
seeing this happen there's a check on
the board on G7 yep and King F6 is uh
force and for Fabby this would be a
terrible start I mean my goodness it
couldn't get get worse uh backto back
losses and uh Maxim Rook D7 looks like
the natural move you want to make well
right now right now he hasing King H6
ooh
interesting
unexpected
unbelievably we have just been told that
Ry who we know has had no time uh but
somehow he's still miraculously in it
and may have escaped against Liam uh
whoa uh wow how does that happen where
did the seon go like right like we left
it right about here where we were
picking up the H Pawn and we thought
King E5 let's go and
somehow okay Liam thought I've got two
I'm two pawns up I must be winning right
and he probably is right
but re played the last about 20 moves
with no time with no time on on
literally two or three seconds on the
clock left and he's managed to survive
this it's so frustrating you play a guy
a player who with no time and then they
never
blunder and it's just infuriating it's
like it's not even difficult anymore
because the pawn F5 gets picked up next
you can't keep the Rook on the f file oh
Rook
f43 E3 and yeah it's it's not even
tricky anymore it's it's it's fairly
straightforward oh this has got to be
heartbreak for Liam he had it in the bag
I mean that Bishop on C6 the Pawn's just
moving forward the only way that c Pawn
could have disappeared was becoming a
queen yeah but that did not happen and
now it just looks like this is going to
end in the next
few yeah and the the very critical
moment I think we can pinpoint
specifically where it all went wrong for
for Liam uh this position that that I
have on the screen here so far so good
and I think he made a very
understandable move here because your
Bishop is hanging so why not give a
check in the center of the board but
that actually allowed white some
semblance of stability after King E3
with uh Rook C5 or rookie a check coming
in If instead of that move Black Goes
let's say Rook
A2 uh you do have to be you do have to
be certain that this end game is winning
but I think you are fairly certain after
the king four because with the King cut
off from Below those are reasonably well
known to be completely lost what white
wants is King on F1 in these positions
but you're never getting you're not
getting there and after Rook A2 you also
create a third of Rook A3 check and very
very importantly with the bishop steal
on C6 The Rook on C8 is completely cut
off from play so white has to make some
very very uncomfortable moves just to
continue the game like maybe you can you
have to play King C3 but now I can just
go F5 F4 and white still has no checks
totally different and you just get
completely run over and once he played
before this is not a draw yet but this
is where it started looking like it
could be a draw at some point because
it's a huge Improvement for white to be
able to to start giving checks start
attacking attacking pawns and pushing
yeah this this is still this is still
probably winning with precise play but
you do have to play precisely and rookie
one check is just a massive massive
mistake blender W very resourceful stuff
here wow by Ray Robson playing on
seconds and this one
uh it does continue okay but you just
have the B Pawn now yeah I think he
actually played a five of four here
judging by what I see on the screen he
went for this as his best chance of
winning the game which is a bit
surprising because it really doesn't
look like it will win and King and King
C5 so white is eventually going to give
up the Knight for the B Pawn and the
white king will snap up the F Pawn this
will finish very soon and that's it he's
going to take on B5 put the king F3 snap
up the F4 Pawn huge save for uh Ray and
big one and also the hand chaks and we
see a smile of relief
there Liam's not going to be smiling and
Anish with a shake of his head is not
going to be smiling exactly as uh again
we're seeing uh
Yana well I something he he's very very
fortunate to save this game
uh uh let's jump back to the game of mvl
because that move King H6 was a real
surprise move for me and it didn't
really change matters because after King
H6 immediately uh we saw Rook D5 to D7
and uh mvl has doubled his Rooks on the
seventh Rank and he's got uh this is
actually very cute because King H6 was
losing but it was losing for a very
specific reason which wasn't spotted by
the players and now the game the game uh
continues and might even not be so easy
to win anymore for uh for mvl where was
the win after King H6 you can take on E5
and then go King
F4 and everything
collapses maybe even not shockingly I
wanted to say shockingly but maybe there
is no particular shock in that Rook A7 I
guess and just we we start collecting
everything uh because you're you're just
sort of one tempo short from being able
to play Rook G2 and not lose the entire
King side Queen side both both both
sides okay uh what we do have is a
position where uh it it feels like white
should be winning but maybe it's not as
easy anymore uh H4 actually no H4 is
very strong and Mach is not saying Fab
escaped no so it's a pawn sacrifice and
you bring your Rook to attack the H Pawn
he does it recaptures now there are
always these threats of pushing the FB
forward I apologize I'm just going to uh
refresh my board as we have two games
remaining mvl Wesley so is trying to
lose I don't I don't know if he will if
he will succeed but he's kind of trying
to lose here mv's trying to lose well
not really I mean he's trying but he's
working yeah he's working towards toward
F4 is on the board and the pawns are
pushing and with two Rooks remaining
this is danger zone for white yeah if
you drop if you drop a king Back to
each2 Black just goes Rook H2 and if you
take on A6 right I wouldn't be shocked
if this was already like sign
significantly dangerous territory yeah
it says minus four wow E4 E3 E4 e3
coming in and the king the king is the
king is so weak and also if you play
King E1 maybe even King G4 F3 is coming
in so right uh yeah happens the third R
if this happens you can still save the
game here if you if you stop yourself
just in time and not take on A6 but all
of his previous play was to take A6 so
yeah he's gone he's gone King D4 by the
way King D he's gone King D4 and now
after King F5 once again the the engine
suggests you are struggling to make a
draw and why why does it not work for
work for black to go for the direct line
with E3 anymore what happens after E3
how do you react I think we just take
and go King D3 so you trade and there's
a check and you just come back with your
king and after and now I I have frontal
checks as well like I have Rook G1 Rook
F1 to to fall back fall back on if I
need to so this feels like it should be
holding even though it's quite scary as
I just realized Rook H2 creates a threat
of mate in that's a m in one Rook D2 but
but you can actually you can actually go
Rook G1 King H6 can I hide on H6 even
this you can you can even go King F6 and
Rook F2 but after Rook D1 for some
reason the engine says this is not
enough wow but this is turned around who
thought that this position Fab is going
to be the one who'll be pushing now
exactly exactly well like uh Peter said
uh mvl is working hard to not only throw
away an advantage but a very big throw
yeah we see Wesley and and uh Sam uh
finish the game Wesley at some point was
four four draws in this match that's
surprising but let's stay with this for
just a moment mvl uh
so a moment you you you're the move to
play for a win here is King F5 yeah I
wanted to ask you how am I playing for a
win then yeah the move to play for a win
is King F5 and if the captures on A6
happen well this is where you get yeah
we play Rook H1 once again this is
very may be losing yeah and you you have
to go in for something like this and
you're really not sure that like E3
probably already wins your a rook right
I would assume that E3 takes and both F
takes and F3 probably pick you pick you
up yeah but it's just not going to be
enough because Rook
A8 and then I will even drive your king
a bit further
away right and then eventually I will go
Rook E8 take on E1 take on B5 and I will
have enough but
close close this is this is very very uh
you know difficult ter already and time
Tanya what's the clocks it is getting
very tricky for maxim who has to defend
this with 20 seconds Fabiano did go for
the idea of getting the king to join
those two pawns from advancing it's
looking very scary ooh look at that
check using the pin on the F4 Pawn picks
up the Rook the F3 Pawn will give a
check moving forward this is probably
lost this looks lost to me it does I
mean wait a a minute fabby's King is in
perfect position to escort the pawn up
the board and what's this King so do you
come back with
your oh sorry do you go Rook H6 trying
to drive the white king further away
with a check on the D
line that looks very strong actually
that looks very strong looks very very
good might not be the only solution but
feels like the cleanest solution yeah
you just want that Rook H6 Rook D6 or
Rook h8 Rook d8 with a similar idea but
I want to keep that A6 Pawn Defender
just in case
yeah you're you you've won my heart keep
the A6 Pawn defended but at the same
time just as you're saying Drive the
white king away from the promotion
Square so that you're going to pick up
the Rook for sure but you know Peter
this just feels like there there ought
to be something super simple like Rook
G4 Rook H3 uh King G2 and and you say it
and it's on the board Rook G4 is the
move of choice apparently this threw
away the Win w
after after Rook of six this is somehow
no no longer winning
amazing and he played quickly
B3 and and now he's lost again now Fab
is reaching first king as he's ready
just to play King G2 and that was the
idea you wanted to build a bridge of
Rook G4 stopping any checks on the G
line and he does it F2 is coming it's
all about the race right is white in
time with C4 this was a mistake take and
it's a draw oh my gosh I I like I'm I'm
just actually no no motion reconsidered
and is is now winning again you have to
go Rook G3 uh no R G3 maybe was cleaner
but I I like your Rook G6 idea suddenly
yeah you can still drop it back to G6
after after King E3 very nice or G8 so
you can't take the pawn because of the
check and you lose the Rook exactly and
now he's played C4 has mvl but comes
check and this Pawn is going to make a a
queen and
force The Rook to give itself up but
this should be straightforward right
Peter just F2 uh Rook G8 was much weaker
than Rook
G6 wow are we splitting hairs or no we
are just the difference between winning
and losing apparently really which I
don't understand and wouldn't even
attempt to explain but uh R G6 was
winning and Rook G8 somehow
isn't well you said it Tanya that uh
when you have had that opportunity to
play Rook H6 and just defend the pawn
keep it nicely tucked away and somehow
that's making a huge difference by the
way C5 a very committal move on the
board and the first thing I want to ask
is what happens if black gives a check
on d8 you go to the C file I'm guessing
because King E3 King e one looks over
completely uh completely winning so King
he gives it check from E2 instead Rook
E2 and King
D1 how is he moving that King from F1 to
queen that F2 exactly
exactly
um am I playing Rook to E3 with the
intention of just taking a
pawn no I C6 C7 I on C7 finally by the
way he has put his Rook on the sixth
ring and it had to be done right yes cuz
if you allow the white Pawn to get to C7
you can't improve your position exactly
but at the same time now he doesn't have
the move Rook D6 check to liberate his
King Rook E2 uh Peter is this I think uh
we probably don't have enough time to
actually delve into this but I I think I
sort of figured out what was happening
there it's happened C6 played he doesn't
care about the B3 Pawn he just wanted on
C7 so that you make sure that Black's
Rook is tied down to the defense of cwn
and that is exactly what he's done I
think this is now a very trivial draw as
well because black really has no
progress to make and you can just
Shuffle on probably the D1 D2
squares and uh who although A5 with the
King on D1 black could consider playing
A5 B takes A5 B4 maybe what you actually
do is you play Rook along the like Rook
F7 here and and if the king comes out
you start giving checks and uh
eventually driving it back to F1 and
that maybe is a draw and the reason
Peter you're saying that is because if
the king is on D1 once you sacrific the
a Pawn on A5 which is the only winning
idea that black has to try to push the B
Pawn is that B1 is a check I don't like
the idea of B1 lending with check it
worries me I don't know if that's enough
to win but it definitely worries me
quite a bit and as you can see he's
reaching for the Rook he doesn't like
allowing that either wow that's really
nice full board awareness there and and
and now I think the the winning attempt
for black will be something like getting
the king over to E4 and then actually
swapping the C7 Pawn for the F2 pawn and
trying to win the B4 Pawn somehow but
it's probably not realistic yep Rook
G7 I'm just going to refresh my board
everybody don't get angry Rook
G7 so the king comes out and we're going
to see a bunch of
checks yeah and Faby can choose where to
aim aim that King but the logical play
seems seems to be to go to to E4 but he
doesn't believe that is winning so he
goes f one for now or he's just
repeating to get those extra seconds on
the clock that's
too because it feels like the only
winning try you give up the F2 Pawn you
pick up the C7 pawn and try to win on
The Queen side exactly but I do believe
with the King on D2 it's too close
trivial is strong but yeah I think it
should be way I think he's preparing for
those eventualities I guess is but now
Rook to G7 yeah but now after Rook G7
you have to more or less go back to C6
actually have no legal moves yeah Rook
six might be the only the only move
there that makes any sense whatsoever
exactly yeah just r s one of the things
that has absolutely impressed me about
this generation of players is that
technically even when they have less
time they play very well but in this
particular ending Peter we saw some
major mistakes that I don't normally see
at this level but but they are tricky in
I maybe earlier it was more or less
straightforward but specifically
specifically the difference uh claim and
the claim was correct and and the game
uh is is ended in a draw so if we talk
about this position where where he's
gone Rook G8 and that apparently leads
to a draw and Rook G6 wins I think the
difference is very specifically uh let
me just find my place here because it's
uh you've got it uh it's very tricky
hang on so if we go Rook G6 here just to
find it here so if if if white does hang
on a second if white if white does the
same you play C4 Mach gives a check from
E6 machine trades on C4 interesting uh
goes F2 Rook G7 King F1 and this is
winning somehow because you're sort of
just in time ending yeah because you
you're you're not going to be fast
enough as I understand it to deal with
the combined threats of like Rook D6 and
then King E1 or maybe even Rook E2 check
followed by King so you have to go C5 in
this position right yeah let's say we go
C5 and come on Peter yeah and then check
you cannot go forward because King E1
wins on the spot so I have to go back
and then Rook
E4 and this just doesn't work out for
you move by move it it still looks like
it might be a draw but it just isn't you
just have you have to accept it isn't I
guess is is the way to describe it and
the difference and and I couldn't
understand why this wasn't winning in
the game as well after R E8 so I checked
uh and we we get to the same hang on a
second uh with the traded pawns yeah
hang on let me let me let me find it so
this is the game position King D2 and uh
F2 was played in the game allowing white
to play C5 so what happens if we take on
C4 and we say but what's the difference
yes why is this a draw the draw is
because now we can play Rook G6 and
after rookie to check there is this
resource W and rookie one check and
picking up the queen which doesn't exist
in the other position this is just
because the Rook was on the sixth and we
couldn't play Rook G6 right oh my gosh
but I mean good luck spotting this on
the yeah with seconds
on and and also this was an I want to
say I want to say that when when you get
there when you get there and you're
deciding between Rook G6 and Rook
G8 I
think from the ous point of view you
want it as far away as
I think you taught to go as far away as
possible so that it never hangs you know
right there's no Tempo yeah putting
putting distance between the oppon
opposing pieces and your Rook so I think
your hand actually plays Rook G8 here
and that throws away a win thank you
Peter Tanya as we get ready for break
just tell us our standings nothing
changed actually big as we had five
draws and a fighting fighting Jaws
peaceful ends but the games were
anything but peaceful and there we stand
with Ali Resa Li Sams everyone just gets
one point after the draw the standings
don't change which means that we still
have three players at the top of the
leaderboard going into the final rapid
round of the day we see Ali Alam and Sam
with three points they've got to be
feeling good and what a save there by
Maxim vher lra incredible Fighting Chess
and we will be back with more Fighting
Chess in just a few don't go anywhere
the finder round of the day is coming
[Music]
up in 2019 the Missouri Bicentennial
commission along with Governor Mike
Parson approved the building of a
life-size chess board to celebrate the
200th anniversary of the state of
Missouri Dr jeie singfield a lifelong
patron of scouting and Great Rivers
Council board member proposed that the
project be built as an Eagle Scout
project jeie invited 16-year-old Andrew
dowon of troop 6 Jefferson City to take
on this incredibly important
project my name is Andrew dowen and I
belong to troop 6 in Jefferson City
Missouri so my troop um we were down
camping down at the sing fields and jeie
came down and asked you know is anyone
close to getting their eagle or needing
a project uh she had this idea of the
Eagle Scout project chessboard and she
wanted somebody to kind of work with her
to see what we could come up with at the
time I kind of had a project in line but
when she brought up this idea obviously
I I wanted to choose it because it was a
lot better idea than what I had started
prior to this project uh I did not
really know anything about Chess once I
got into this project I downloaded an
app on my phone started playing chess
and I took the uh chess merit badge down
at Scout camp this was a bicentennial
chessboard for the
Historical Society of Missouri there
were a lot of people that helped me with
this project because whenever I got the
pictures from the Historical Society to
engrave onto the granite I wasn't very
familiar with the technology needed to
engrave on there so I needed some
assistance with that and learning how to
do it and after all that I'm pretty sure
I know how to do it now so to engrave
those Edge pieces I went down to the
Lake of the Ozarks Scout Reservation and
we used the epilog laser me and Thomas
Yang did I wasn't really expecting it to
end out this big but as we me and jeie
were working um it just got kind of got
bigger and bigger and bigger which I
didn't have a problem with I thought you
know I can take on a little bit more and
a little bit more and um it ended out to
be a really really cool project so we
had a ribbon cutting of the chess board
and there were a whole bunch of people
there including the governor um the St
Louis chess club the World Chess Hall of
Fame the State Historical Society which
all helped out during this entire
project um jeie was there I had to give
a little speech that I didn't really
know I had to do but that kind of has
taught me a little bit about speaking
too so I think that has helped me too
this project um it's made me real proud
that everyone one is enjoying it like
every time I go down there somebody's
playing um and then they're taking care
of it which really makes me proud cuz me
sinking all that time and everyone else
that's helped me sinking in all that
time like to see people use it but I
also like to see people appreciate
it the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world world for nearly 1,500 years
stop by and learn about the impact of
Chess from our three floors showcasing
the art culture and history of the game
the World Chess Hall of Fame has
something for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiqu stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over over 100 schools throughout the
St Louis city and county the St Louis
chess club has been able to reach over
85,000 students in both in school and
after school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world World thanks to co-founders Dr
jeie Karen singfield and Rex singfield
the St Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and and enjoy the game of chess
we also promote Chess at the highest
levels hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and Le ures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chest
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
family-friendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the worldclass St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutique.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been been
able to reach over 85,000 students in
both in school and after school programs
we created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
leis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting stlewis chess club.org
[Music]
education welcome back everyone as we're
about to kick off the final round three
of the day we've had a spectacular
fighting chest lots of turnarounds lots
of hits and misses and let's take a look
at our standings going into this game
three and we've got at the top of the
leaderboard with three points Ali res
Alam and Sam then a two points we've got
four players Maxim Anish Jeffrey and Ray
Robson at the bottom of the board but
with quite a save there Fabby and Yan
surviving the positions that they had
remarkable and the fact that Fabby
nearly turned that completely round is
shocking tell us about the pairings for
this third and final round of the day
let's take a look and speaking of Fabian
Yang they do face each other so that's
going to be a big one for these two
players looking at climbing up on that
leaderboard we've got Ali Rea against
Maxim Anish giri plays Wesley so it is
another All-American face off with Sam
against Ray Robson and Liam plays
Jeffrey Jean let's jump into the game of
fabii versus nepo because I'm looking
this position and we're seeing the Four
Knights English and the move E2
E4 um there was a time where literally
everybody and his brother played G3 and
that was the end of the story then E3
became popular then crazily enough D3
became popular A3 and there was a moment
that nobody played E4 and now it's
become one of the go-to moves Peter this
is I would argue that this the the
second the second most popular after G3
yeah G3 still stays number one but E4 is
a very very topical line and black has a
choice here between playing Bishop C5
and Bishop B4 Bishop B4 chosen by by
Fabi here I'm pretty sure he played both
a bunch of times and also I think with
both colors uh so they they will know
this quite well uh D3 D6 and the
Strategic fight here
is the reason I think why nobody used to
play four in the in the olden days is
you you seem to have completely
abandoned control over the D4 square and
you would have been you know chewed out
by a coach and like what are you doing
like why why is this your position by
move seven but it turns out you can sort
of play around it you can sort of ignore
that this is happening and uh gain space
on the Queen's side in some cases also
gain some space on the king side and uh
this is a kind of a debated position
which is surprisingly sharp in some
cases uh obvious questions excuse me for
asking the obvious ones you've played
Knight C3 to A4 to hunt down this bishop
B B6 and then didn't take it and didn't
take it it's one of those the threat is
stronger than the execution you know
things which let a bail out can you
believe that Tanya you use that line on
me I can't believe
it to be yeah you have done once um yeah
and this is now a really weird type of
position where uh black importantly
created some space for the bishop to
retreat so white can no longer
comfortably hunt it down with Knight C3
kn2 because it will run away all the way
to to A7 and white also has a bit of an
issue with choosing uh not where white
can't really Castle Queen side anymore
with the Rook already on one but when to
Castle King side because I think if you
do it in certain spots black could
decide that the appearance of the King
on G1 is just a signal to start running
the pawns down the board keeping perhaps
your king in the center not even
castling que ins side just keeping the
King on E8 where it's quite safe because
it's going to be very very difficult for
white to open things up up in the center
so this is actually I very much like
that we have this on the board because I
think this promises to be a very
interesting uh strategic fight thank you
Peter and uh uh let's take a look at
their head-to-head matchups uh how do
they stack up uh Tanya wow another quite
a lopsided head tohe head that is with
eight wins to 18 losses w wow so y 27
draws they have played they've measured
each other often but I didn't realize
that Fabby suffers uh badly yeah with 18
losses there so trying to level this one
up and we see a lot of Retreats have
happened the Bishop from D4 has gone
back to A7 Fabby develops the bishop to
G5 right just uh so there on the bo yeah
tickling that Knight and uh I think we
saw Queen E6 yeah Queen E6 play the
question is how do we react to Knight G5
now that's the
98 yeah but then why didn't he play 98
on the previous move right question I
think 98 loses material now Bishop
G4
correct going with my queen only Square
to only Square now both Bishop both
Bishop E7 and Knight E7 just win the
exchange right right yeah yeah that's ay
trick yeah I'm not I mean he he must
have something after 9 D5 but I'm not
quite sure why you would play Queen E6
and encourage it right yeah I'm I'm very
confused because sorry I'm just going to
refresh my board it's on the bo5 on the
board and now Yan slows down and starts
thinking do you think it's one of those
the way classic Yan moments where he
rushes with Queen to E6 and then you
just realize you're in big trouble so
yeah think you're right apparently
apparently Bishop A7 was already a
mistake we were we were okay after
castles Bishop A7 is not very precise
here unsurprisingly because it allows
Bishop G5 so this already is quite quite
problematic for black because you would
like maybe to play Knight E8 but maybe
the reason he didn't do it is because he
didn't he didn't like that either right
very understandably but now he's just
dead lost because C7 is also hanging
right there's just no yeah he's gone KN
E8 but now Bishop G4 yeah he will he
will just play a position down a full
exchange yeah uh because there's nothing
else of the opening you're really not
seeing any compensation for that
exchange it's all happened as we were
pointing out Bishop G4 Queen G6 on the
board and a pleasant Choice here for
Abby does it make a difference whether
you start with Bishop E7 or Knight E7 or
is there a preference here well
amazingly you can even go Bishop D2
apparently and there's no defense
against Bishop F5 and B5 is a threat as
well yeah so so the engine goes F5
Bishop F5 Queen F7 and yeah you you you
you know what this position is you you
don't need to
Awful Bish D2 I mean is I feel Bishop E7
or 97 is just so much more human in that
position position yeah instead of Bishop
to D2 uh it'll be interesting to see
what's Fab's Choice Peter your
sensitivity with the board somehow I
mean it doesn't uh doesn't Inspire much
confidence considering we we have two
weeks ahead of us well yeah you're going
to get with me failing failing to click
on on things but I you know it it's
amazing to think that these players who
are so incredibly well prepared we talk
about Challenger nappo who's been in two
World Championship matches he's
easily one of the most prepared prep
players in the world and he's lost after
a dozen moves I mean come on that's it's
not this game right yasa if you just
look at the full day he's had he goes 86
against Sam seian walking into that
whole tactical Skirmish that loses on
the spot in game one right game two he
barely survived against Anish after a
very difficult position exactly um if I
could guess a hazard to guess I'd say
jet leg uh you talk about all the All
American Derby
uh but uh the the challenge to see who's
the who's the number one French player
is uh in full swing right now as we have
oi rais versus number one against the
French number two exactly and let's see
what we have we have one of these Mooky
bind positions with
B5 and
D5 very exciting stuff going on here
everybody while these two are are friend
and you know they play for the same team
but I also feel that when they get on
the board Maxim was French number one
for the longest time exactly until ala
came into thect I I think there's a lot
to prove when they play against each
other and they take that in a very
competitive way exactly I mean I you you
said it very well they are definitely
friends off the board rivals on the
board and they want to be the best chess
players they can be and sometimes you
just it it's nice to have a rival that's
pushing you right I mean Muhammad Ali
had Joe Frasier yeah and without Joe
Frasier there would have been no
Muhammad Ali and sometimes you need that
kind of rival what what do we have in
the head to
head now that's ban that's the first
head to head that we've seen all day
that gu pretty much balanced with seven
wins to Al Rosa to six losses so a
really close fight we can expect between
these two speech ja Specialists
absolutely but at the same time we have
a very exciting position on the board
unless it's all Theory Peter I was
trying to remember there was a recent
game which yanomi played in the uh levit
of Chess week tournament in Amsterdam
which which was very very similar I
think with black against Wesley so which
ended in a draw but Yan was busted for
about a couple of moves he told me
afterwards I didn't notice but he told
me that he mixed up the move order and
was busted but I think judging I I
couldn't really do any kind of an
in-depth dive but judging by the very
cursory uh investigation I did while you
were you were speaking this appears to
be the right move order and black should
be holding and this is a very sharp
position because I think what white
would like to get here is something
along the lines of takes 95 95 Queen D5
we take on A6 we go Queen E2 yes there
is some vulga slbo type compensation but
you are a pawn up yeah the problem with
that is that if you go e Tak D5 you
instantly lose to Rook takes C3 followed
by Knight D5
followed by Knight E3 followed by
knight4 and that opens up the diagonal
for the bishop and everything just
collapses this is just a dead loss
position as you can see by the
evaluation which means that if you want
to try to get that position you can't
start with the capture with the pawn you
have to start with the Knight capture
okay and then once again you're not
getting it because I will be taking on
B5 and not D5 here and the pawn on D5 is
weak it probably gets picked up
reasonably quickly so black gets enough
counter play here as well and also
importantly if you play F3 F4 here which
for a second I thought was very logical
exactly if the KN goes somewhere we go
E5 we probably just win but the Knight
goes nowhere right Rook takes C3 as a
killer that's very good yeah white has
to take the Rook we take on e4 we go
Knight G4 and we're very proud yeah and
we are a full exchange down but look at
those beautiful beautiful horses exactly
and that really nice Bishop on G7 yes
yes that's a guided missile so we like
that uh where was the novelty because
somehow your games disappeared uh yeah
um it's not it's not very clear exactly
when you know it's still hang on this
can't really be this is uh maybe yeah
you just oh you turned off the uh
opening book or something and another
update that Faby did go for to move
Bishop to E7 so uh we left it uh in that
moment we felt Yan has made a big
mistake out of the opening and it looks
like are just going to be up an extra
exchange definitely and you're just
seeing
uh I want to say Yan looking at the
board and he's wondering you know did
how why did I wake up this morning
something something was in The Breakfast
the coffee it it's all gone wrong here
in day one for uh Yan let's jump to the
game between Anish and Wesley so uh the
two players are playing a very
theoretical dispute and I know that this
is for some reason this particular
variation this whole line I've really
associated with Wesley yes like he has
been Cutting Edge for some time but I
did want to point out that you know if
you showed this position to a puzzle
Rush moment I don't know how many people
would find the move Bishop A6 what do
you think about that time it's a really
nice move and uh Anish really showing
that he's tactically fully aware right
now and that's actually a really
beautiful way to defend your Bishop in
some ways exact get out of the way and
at least mess spoil the guy's Pond
structure if you take if you take then
you're super happy because you take on
B4 and then the a files opened up and
everything's fallen into place cuz
you're threatening Rook to A6 the Knight
goes to C2 but the C5 square is attack
and maybe we can just quickly show that
line that after Knight C2 if you pick up
on A6 you can't still pick up on you can
start with a check but just to show the
idea that Knight B4 runs into Bishop C5
check and I I hate to slightly rain on
your parade here but this is all still
very much the of course it
is the yeah and uh lots of games too I
imagine right yeah high profile games as
well uh Ivan Sado Lopez against we way
back in 2014 as well so this is not
even a stroke of Genius by Anish giri
it's something he's aware of well it's
it just once again showcases that he is
incredibly well booked up and knows
stuff which is something feels like to
be the entire by the way I players play
the Joko piano for ages and it's like
nobody aspires to play D3 D4 anymore
Peter I don't think that's entirely true
I think uh we've already seen in this
tournament a couple of games where this
uh but this early I meant to say you
know you haven't played Knight to G3 yet
you know that is that is fair but even
so far even in the first three rounds
this is I think the second occasion
where this happened because there was
also this game that Ray should have lost
to leang where he had uh this setup with
with a KN steel back on B on B okay um
yeah and uh even here D6 D5 is something
I would definitely consider I'm not sure
if it's the best move it's the move that
the engine suggests D6 D5 yeah people
also could just you could there's
nothing particularly wrong with just
playing let's say Bishop D7 here and
great you've got and and continuing
development but the the Way Concrete
yeah the the way to make the most
progress
towards definite equality would be to uh
meet D4 with D5 and uh seems like it's
working I guess after he takes D5 we
take with the queen we're not that
worried about Bishop B3 because we can
just drop back to D6 there's never any
Knight G5 we'll replay H6 right doesn't
even look like it's you know that scary
phased yeah Knight A3 Knight A3 we take
on D4
B5 I guess we take on E1 and yeah Machin
goes Queen D7 and says this is really
not that
bad that's looks looks a bit worrisome
but we do have by the way Bishop D7 but
the move
D5 yeah that that that looked very very
forcing and uh clear uh Bishop D7 A4 are
we still in known territory
then there's still some games yeah
actually Jeffrey Jeffrey had it with
black I was wondering if that was
relevant but they might know but uh he
wasn't playing anyone who is playing
this game so that's still a game played
in 2021 which uh Jeffrey Shong was
actually beaten by uh John Burke all
right uh one of our uh leaders
tournament co-leaders Liam he is up
against uh Jeffrey Jang and let's see
what they have played oh an old favorite
of mine and yeah and mine Jack King
check I was very proud of myself uh I
had the occasion to to try and play from
the white side I kind of welcomed it
but uh it's not it doesn't refute the
the the black the black option but it's
very very playable the idea of playing
H4 and then playing D3 and then in some
cases playing H5 and some places playing
quieter is is definitely very sound and
and black does need to know what they
what they're doing kn6 D3 KN D4 played
KN B5 we're actually still following one
of my games against NV actually two of
my games against mvl is how did you do
now that I think I drew one and I lost
one and the one I lost I had a very good
position in but uh that is so annoying
preparing for a particular player you
get the position you want yeah that's
one of the worst feelings in the world
and then you lose your prep yeah and
that was all in in World Cups 2017 2019
so there were Stakes were reasonably
high as well so yeah those are not very
very pleasant memories uh but our game
GL we brought him up absolutely yeah our
game here continued Bishop F4 KN B5 this
is uh I have I haven't played that and
yeah white will eventually with the King
on G1 the king will either get out or
white could also I assume go for some
kind of a rook lift with Rook H3 and
King can just stay on G1 H5 continues
being sort of very much on the menu but
seems like after a very logical Bishop
D6 black isn't really doing all that
poorly right I would still probably take
white here just because I sort of like
this General structure know play Rook H3
here but apparently a huge mistake and
after Queen C7 I already failed to
equalize though I hate that there we go
nice okay well we'll leave uh Liam and
uh Jeffrey to work what game didn't we
take a look at Tanya well there's a lot
of action along all the games uh just a
quick update that Fabby does have an
extra exchange that's going to go on for
a while should we go back to well let's
just take a look at because it kind of
seems a little bit groy we left it here
and you know if I'm going to win an
exchange I'm going to include a trade of
pieces because the the closer I get to
an ending the happier I am so 97 check
would have been my choice and that's a
that's good traditional chess wisdom
that still stands right if you're up
material want to try and trade off as
many pieces on the way and in fact as
the game did continue that Knight which
wasn't traded off has become a piece
that gives black counterplay against
that exchange well the Knight is sitting
in the middle of the board Knight to D4
Bishop he took the rook
and again well this is now actually
quite unclear because white white has
the advantage still because of course of
course he has has more Rooks but you
have to play very very precisely because
what happened was black established this
fantastic Knight on D4 thank you white
now has this really really poor Bishop
on H3 which does absolutely nothing and
also the pawn on C5 is now vulnerable
clear very vulnerable and the engine
goes King H1 with a very specific plan
of meeting Bishop takes C5 with Queen C1
and this is why we played King H1 to
stop Knight E2 check from being a fork
and that wins back some material because
E5 is very vulnerable if you take Rook
fc1 you can't really you can't really
protect the E5 pwn Pawn uncomfortably
because it you just don't have the
pieces for it and and things start
falling well the engine goes H6 and uh
says white is better but
considering it was screaming white is
winning five moves ago this is a massive
massive Improvement in uh in Yan's
fortunes you can definitely imagine him
not losing this position at all so yeah
Fabby Fabby maybe thought the game was
just over when he got here he thought
okay uh my opponent is really having a
horrible horrible day and I should just
well isn't fabbi on a roller an
emotional roller coaster as well because
he just had this game where MB where he
looked like he was dead to the wind
turned it around completely was maybe
winning then made a draw from maybe a
winning position and Tanya now you know
he's taken a a completely winning
position it's been an absolutely up and
down day for Fabby and it's clear these
are like first first day jitters that
we're seeing by the very best in the
world and you're right you know you win
an Exchange in less than what 15 moves
out of the opening you pretty much think
you're going to have the point really
soon
right you've got some questions to
answer uh Fabby firstly needs to find
this idea that Peter pointed out of
getting that Queen to C1 not the easiest
idea to spot no I wouldn't say so and by
the way he didn't spot it he didn't play
King H1 he did play instead Knight to D6
which visually looks very impactful
because you do want to uh capture this
Pawn on uh B7 but then you start to
think about itanya you know that Knight
on
B7 might be like one of the worst places
on the board it's gone too far no way
home like okay so I take I'm assuming
you want to take with the Rook but with
the Rook you can take on D6 with the
bishop so you have to take with the
Knight and now you know like if I had my
Pawn on A5 and my Bishop on B4 you would
be crying right we we just start by
taking on A3 and yeah why am I even
worse with black I understand I'm
probably maybe even slightly worse still
but we're going to see this happened by
the way yeah because this night is on B7
and I was it Alexis
sherov versus Gary kaspar was this but
that night was significantly more
miserable than yes exactly exactly but
did that make a searing impression on
your mind as well that was that was one
of the all amazing yeah uh the Knight on
B7 I what's the engine of Val machun
still says it's significantly better for
white you go King H1 King H1 G3 F4 and
eventually I guess that Knight gets
rerouted a55 C4 yeah and C4 will be a
good Square for it okay well we'll keep
that in mind again we're going to go to
the all French derby here and we'll see
how uh fua handled this move D5 well
guess what
he said I'm going to bail out I'm not
going to play F4 I'm not going to take
on D5 I'm not going to take on A6 I'm
going to play Knight C6 and after the
trade trade E5 you hit the Knight only
Square because Knight H5 G4 was a bit of
a could be but there's E5 hanging but
you really want your knight on the edge
of the ball yeah yeah I was about to say
night I'll probably just end up playing
F4 and just saying I'm not sure you're
happy about this guy Queen takes D5 also
on tap he did play by the way uh Knight
back to E8 F4 Knight to
C7 that's all we caught up with the
players uh somehow I thought there was
more moves Rook C1
and uh early takes I mean in a sense if
you play the move E6 you've got a French
defense position without the light
squared bishop and you're happy on the
other hand you know maybe
the D4 Square can be uh very useful for
white uh what's your early take would
you prefer white or black I think I
would prefer white but I also feel that
black has solved a lot of problems here
already I want to play E6 I want to get
that Knight to B5 or for a night trade I
want to try and get rid of the knights
if I can open up the a line if you take
on B5 uh I'm not going to allow you to
jump to D4 right very easily without any
trades okay and it just feels like it
should be in balance right now okay fair
I'm not sure who i' prefer Peter jump in
just just your preference not
necessarily the engine vow which is as
you see Triple over the years I've I've
preferred these types of positions for
white where you have the the potential
of uh playing along the C file end games
are probably better for you because you
have a chance of creating an outside
passer but I think it's quite concrete I
think apart from just saying okay I can
play e76 at some point and play a French
you can also just play for the F7 F6
break and say I I don't need to just
assume this is the structure for the
next 20 moves I can just start digging
more or less immediately Rook d8 also
creates an annoying threat of D5 D4
let's say they go Knight E2 and we can
Machin suggests just very simply putting
the Knight on E6 and just playing F6
next move pretty much I like it and says
uh I don't want to wait I don't want to
even discuss those end games that I just
mentioned a bit earlier no end games for
you let's play a concrete game where I
will start immediately challenging your
uh your central structure
and seems okay for black but still you
have to be careful of course because I
think
statically uh this has the potential of
being a bit dangerous for for black if
uh not yeah if play doesn't arrive in
time I think you you could uh struggle a
bit again I want to go uh to the game of
Sam and Ray robs and when we left it we
did we did see that move A2 A4 not an
intuitively obvious move by the way uh
for white you've just you you've got the
central Pond Duo and you would think
that the first thing you want to do is
get developed you know Knight A3 Bishop
E3 sorry Tanya please yeah no I was just
about to say on on your uh remark about
the move A4 I kind of play these
positions a little bit with black and I
really like to create some chances on
the queen side with the move B5 at some
point as black as black I want to get B5
I want to get A4 or B5 B4 and I think
the move A4 really stops that play
you're also not you're crying when I I'm
happy with A4 is all I'm saying and I
think that Knight on B1 I was just about
to say it becomes a lot flexible where
you want to take out to and we see some
moves have happened some trades have
happened and that's the drawback of the
move A4 as you were saying that it gives
black the sff of B4 to jump in with the
Knight exactly we have a nice and
balanced position what uh Peter would
say a good fight on the board three
results black has the two Bishops white
has the
Center I'm not sure that Bishop H3 is
necessarily a threat but you know it's a
yeah in the watch yeah it exists I'd
probably as white here I'd be inclined
to play a move like Bishop F4 my Bishop
on D2 just feels like it's in the way of
the Rooks and I'm just searching for a
plan thereafter so we'll keep an eye on
that and uh turn matters over to Peter
yeah this is a I'm very happy you said
that because what you turn matters over
yeah uh because no the point about the
bishop on the4 because to my eyes it was
a very striking decision here by uh by
Sam not the play Bishop before because
it seems like C is is very specifically
inviting us to play Bishop F4 but D5 E5
and I guess uh something about the
calculations of the move Knight E4 make
it better for white to have the bishop
on D2 rather than on F4 I'm not entirely
sure why that is wow
uh let's try and compare if black does
the same
here come
on no not going to
happen just not going to happen for me
today okay wow so in this position after
Knight E4 the big difference
is Bishop takes A5 wins okay okay and
WIS if he actually if he actually played
Bishop D2 because he saw this then going
to be I am going to be in Eternal so
Queen F5 you want to go Knight F6 yes
this is super nice and you don't have
expl just to explain to the viewers
normally the tactic here that makes this
whole line unplayable for black is the
immediate Knight of six check
seemingly winning the piece but black
responds by putting more pieces on
praise and defending the bishop on F5
and if you take the queen it it's just a
trade leading to a very unclear end game
right so we're luring the queen away
first by playing Bishop takes A5 and if
the queen goes away from the control of
the F6 Square this actually does
win the black position just completely
destroyed and you can more or less
resign here this is a very very
beautiful tactic and if if it actually
is the reason he played Bishop D2 over
Bishop F4 here you you have to take your
hat off to to Sam yeah very nice Bishop
B6 or k G1 Queen D7 all on the board and
we haven't seen Bishop F4 yet not yet
interesting that the engine just says
triple Zer our predecessors really had a
very strong belief both in the two
Bishops as well as the central Pond Duo
and I think the central Pond Duo is lot
lessened in terms of advantage that we
used to think but the two Bishops Remain
the two Bishops advant going ask you
because I am very much s of in both of
those camps very strongly like I I
absolutely adore playing with the bishop
pair but also as somebody who's played a
lot of Royal lus in my life I think I
would be quite happy with white here mhm
despite not having the two Bishops
because I really like the situation
where I have E4 D4 and the Knights on
the two good squares already uh so I was
going to ask you yes sir like without
looking at the habitual 0000 on the
screen let's say 30 years ago which side
do you better for white with the bishop
on F4 yeah I I I would prefer uh even
though I do respect the two Bishops I
like the Central Pawn de I'm I'm amazed
as a groom Feld player and you've been
playing against D4 and E4 your entire
life you're used to seeing them on those
squares Tanya way in here what do you
like the Central Pawn Duo over the two
Bishops or would like the bishop and I
play these positions with black and I
find them quite Dynamic to play with and
it's uh it's a game for three results
and I think both sides have their trumps
but I like the bishop bear and it's an
open position and once white does
advance with the central pawns it opens
up even more giving a lot of chances and
that move A4 did create a weakness on B3
at some point for the Bishops to come in
so I'm team uh Bishop team Bishop here
okay very cool we will continue our
March and we're going to go to Fabby and
Yan's position because when we left it
there was this Knight on B7 and I have
to tell you that was really spoiling the
party uh G2 G3 is how Fabby continued
the game Queen E7 and okay obviously
you're you're threatening to pick it up
this bishop pardon me this
Knight and queen A4 hits the bishop on
A3 so you can't immediately take the
Knight and I was going to say already
I'm feeling so good about this I mean
even if I did fall for Rook takes B7 and
allow you to trade and take the bishop
I'm looking at this Knight and I'm going
I've got really great compensation
anyway uh yeah that's that's a stallion
right there yeah not a pony it's not a h
it's a stallion and we're up to date and
I'm sure you know the engine once again
loves the material but I don't know from
the Practical point of view yeah it
still loves the material well it it is a
full exchange and also that that night
on B7 that was wor it's back on a good
square there's really no I was being
being a hopeless romantic that I am I
was kind of wondering if I can do
something stupid like this but the
answer is just no Queen C8 is winning I
assume Bishop G2 is also winning
although less cleanly mhm and if there
is no immediate counterplay on the queen
side on the king side and they have to
do something like Knight F6 and allow
white to
consolidate it's still not going to be
uh easy to win uh at all for for Fabi
because that Knight on D4 is a very very
strong piece and uh the the weakness on
A6 got picked up but the second one on
C6 is well protected the black king is
very safe on G7 but Yan did something
wrong here Peter because I'm looking at
the position after
20 uh what is it 26 G3 G3 and I'm
thinking okay I've got a pawn I've got
my knight stallion on D4 uh shouldn't I
be playing like C5 and Bishop B4 yeah
and how it is it really that bad no I I
also think that it really wasn't
necessary to just give up on A6 uh so I
think maybe he underestimated Queen A4 I
think what happened there is he thought
Queen E7 forces the Knight to go away
and then he will establish the kind of a
position that we were kind of aiming for
right yes exactly not A5 here because I
blundered the point but instead of A5
Rook A8 or something we do some we do
something sensible you like grou B5 by
A5 exactly and yeah shockingly even this
apparently somehow better for white
which I just don't believe honestly like
I I would be I would feel that I'm very
much in the game here as black me too
very very confused by how much it loves
the the white position here but I think
he may have Mis judged Queen A4 and of
course you would prefer the Aon was
still on the
board yeah and well once I see Queen
takes A6 I just feel like White's
Advantage has clarified let's put it
that way yeah and again I want to go to
uh our tournament leader Liam uh co-
tournament leader Jeffrey Jang because
well some very uh peculiar things have
happened um
E5 uh Rook H3 the move that uh Peter
liked uh you got the uh a Rover Rook up
and over uh Queen D2
F5 my goodness I would not have reached
for the F Pawn what do you think about
that F5 aasan B3 castles
H5 I don't know F5 that's
it's but it does give you counterplay as
well along the F line your queen on D4
now after the castle after Black's
Castle you are eyeing the F line and the
F2 Pawn okay it it's a double edge move
but I kind of liked
it yeah but you've left behind this guy
a long-term weakness Queen he trades and
I think he wants to put the bishop on D4
oh def vacated the D4 Square for the
bishop yeah definitely I think that uh
okay so let let's just go concretely
Rook I'm assuming let's give a check
let's get out of Dodge and can you go
Bishop E5 here or Bishop D4 one of the
two yeah Bishop E5 let's go with Bishop
it's a more forcing move at least yeah I
agree Bishop E5 is far more
forcing yeah yeah not comfortable to
move yeah I was just I was just thinking
that we would be able to play Queen and
he's played Rook C2 we might be we might
have that on the board actually Queen A1
has been played and Rook C1 would only
be a repetition except except in the
Soviet School of Chess you always
repeated once just to show who was in
the D the boss yes exactly I wanted I
wanted to ask what price they just
repeat here because I honestly it
doesn't feel to me like white is better
no uh and
uh it's not illogical to just play Rook
C1 Rook C2 but both these guys are we've
seen Jeffrey play on for quite some time
in in the previous round exle yeah but
yeah there there's already been a couple
of repetitions and I don't know if he
plays King H2 having Rook C1 is just
drawn on the spot yeah that's the third
time I think I think that will be the
third time so now is the now is the
moment for him to uh to make a decision
but that's the thing right decision with
King H2 is it really a big decision to
play on because it's hard to see the
advantage that white really has after
tra I don't see big Advantage it's a
still in your DNA to repeat the position
and to show who's boss I don't do it
that often I do it I've become very very
nervous in time troubles as as the years
gone by like I I used to be completely
fine being short on time and right I
know longer am I really hate it and also
the definition of what is being short
time changed drastically from two
minutes which was luxury to 2 minutes
which is now Panic yeah yeah like 5 for
10 now throws me into you know cold
sweats yeah yeah really wasn't the case
when I was a kid uh but as we see these
these guys are very very ambitious and
and play on and they have indeed played
on with the move Queen C1 how about you
T Tanya you uh let's repeat once let's
repeat twice let me show you it's my
choice I think that's a really
professional way to approach the
position and I I often see the top guys
do that right but for me personally if
I've decided that I want to play on I
try not to repeat unless there's a plus
10 plus five I need those extra seconds
because if I do repeat I find myself
falling into yes I find myself thinking
that do I want to take a draw do I want
to beow do I really believe in this
position good point so I think if I want
to play on I take that decision
instantly rather than repeat and take it
soti uh SWS a little seed of doubt
I'm not I for me it does but I think
I've seen a lot of players for whom it's
no doubt at all they just repeat and
then change right they still have a
single track mine but uh it's a personal
choice right what about you Yas would
you it was the Soviet man we grew up
they were the best players in the world
so we copied them and we would repeat
once and twice and three times I was
going to say that there's there's also
the the actual correct correct school of
thought which is says repeat three times
go home have a warm din on on that note
uh Sam did something which is quite
striking he played Knight E2 here which
makes sense positionally but really
doesn't make sense tactically oh what's
going on here Knight takes E4 Queen
takes E4 Bishop C4 and things are Knight
on E2 things are going from bad to worse
and he's gone Bishop takes A5 instead
sort of understandably and uh Ray went
in with Bishop H3 in H3 which told you
yasa that's in the air Bishop H3 is in
the air what what happen somewhat sadly
here because I I really like this idea
and I probably would have convinced
myself to do it as well it's not great
or at least not the best play something
very simple like Bishop F5 here would
have given black a very very big
Advantage I was about to say didn't you
just trade your A5 Pawn for the E4 Pawn
that's a great deal for black you don't
have to go Bishop H3 and it's but but
this is still I understand the the
impulse to do this because it looks very
very scary the White's position looks
scattered and six Rook G6 uncoordinated
yeah and Knight G3 played the engine was
suggesting Rook D3 first was Stronger
for some reason but even Knight G3 is
playable I think this is maybe the issue
and this is what Ray may have
misunderstood that g yeah this includes
the queen in the
defense and you start liking white even
because after all it is a it is a piece
Bishop D no the bishop on A5 defends E1
so Bishop D4 check is not good no not
not working there no because the eh Rook
is hanging in those lines and you can
you really find a way to keep the Queens
on the board after Queen G3 Queen G2
maybe go Queen to F that doesn't really
help it this looks like it's have Knight
takes G3 on and here already Knight
takes G3 may maybe wasn't the greatest
decision uh and the engine suggests you
can just play D6 D5 because you can also
include this idea of going Bishop B8
somewhere and this KN on e4 is annoying
enough that you don't have to
immediately go after additional material
you want Rook A6 Rook A8 Bishop B8 if
let's say if Rook D3 happens you can
even play Queen G4 first and then let's
say Rook E6 Rook A8 this was the way to
continue having played Bishop takes H3
which is once again a very
understandable decision a decision I
quite like in spirit but maybe not the
best move because the very simple move
Bishop F5 was stronger and now we're
here no we're not here yet yeah he's
still thinking after
FG the knights have been traded and yeah
it's it's going to work out for Sam
because this position is now quite
simple to play for white you want to
play Queen G2 you want to drop the
bishop back to C3 so that it never hangs
right and and you have to be careful as
black that your Bishop on A7 doesn't
remains a spectator out of the game for
a long while absolutely oh
my but I I'm really stunned by the by
the decision to play Bishop H3 and not
Bishop F5 I would have been patting
myself on the back for a job well done
giving up my A5 Pawn for that Central E4
pawn and you said it you like the two
Bishops I like the center Pawn Duo that
was a big fwn for black to pick up on
and you can just continue playing that
position but Bishop P3 and he played it
so fast as well it was the Temptation
was too great and uh I think he it was
Ill considered that uh you know he
thought there was some knockout blow I
mean he missed something because Bishop
F5 is otherwise so compelling and
they've reached a position now with
Queen on G2 and I think the the
situation has suddenly become much
easier for Sam to play if I'm in white
shoes I know what I'm doing my next few
moves I'm playing Bishop C3 and I'm
trying to trade Rooks and hey I'm I'm a
piece up and it's a big question for re
right does he trade TR queens or does he
fall back with the queen to F4 I would
hate to trade Queens in you really don't
want to I really don't because the
problem as I see it is you've got three
connected pass pawns but they take quite
a lot of time to become factors in the
position whereas you know I'm going to
play Bishop C3 and maybe D5 and B4 B5 so
I would want to keep the Queens on the
board with Queen F4 he does it and it
makes a lot of sense at the same time I
I I am recognizing that it's yeah I mean
I'm even looking at Bishop D2 do you
have time to pick up D4 I'm not sure
let's say I go it's playing with fire
now well I've got H6 in my yes sights so
you go Queen
F6 just a second I'm trying to figure
out where I should go with my king if I
go to F1 you go to F6 and I take wow and
this move the bishop and do you take or
do you move the bishop sorry complicated
position and we and we getting some
results here it this does end with a
draw between the French number one and
the French number two that ended
peacefully and it's been a good day for
Ali Resa it has it has been a been nice
uh work uh for mvl a little bit of a ro
roller coaster ride for him as they're
getting settled in um what do you have
for is in the Fabby versus NEPA match
Yan Will Survive seemingly uh we left it
somewhere around here and uh uh Fabby
went for for a plan that I didn't quite
expect he uh spent some time preparing
this tactical idea that you will see in
a moment Yan played very logically
because the King on H1 might be a target
with KN on D4 being as strong as it is
so playing H5 H4 is perfectly logical
and yeah Faby
uh found this nice looking shot 95 but
what it does is it trades some pieces
off which is what you like but it also
creates this glaring weakness on F2
which you can definitely counterplay
against Pino yeah and if you play Queen
B2 here which seems logical but can just
play Queen F6 and uh you don't really
want to even consider playing F2 F3 you
might actually end up getting M King to
G yeah so this yeah and if you have to
start playing positions like this you
kind of know you're not winning them
it's just this is a monster monster
count to play G Queen H G que H yeah
this this starts looking kind of scary
I'm going to have to play the degree to
the degree that the machine actually
plays D4 here wow Bishop takes D4 Queen
E2 to do the same thing but with a Tempo
but then black can just uh liquidate
into this end game which is very very
comfortably drawn three against one on
one side with with an extra Bishop is
not going to be and then after you take
on G3 do you trade on e4 or you push
that pawn to D4 no you want to trade as
many ponds as possible you you take the
take as much of the board as possible
and you are very very comfortable that
this will be enough now easy draw que to
Queen F6 chosen by by Fabi and yeah this
is now an interesting turning point
because uh that D4 Queen e to that might
have been the time to pull the rip court
because this could go wrong I I think I
agree yeah like I'm just curious is it
already is it already bad for white if
we go
393 yeah you already start and you start
seeing H takes G3 and then on H5 not
Bishop on C5 it's opposite color Bishop
complex right that black Bishop is you
can't challenge it you can't fight it
and it's quite a Monster yeah the
machine the machine says it's still a
draw but the way it makes that draw is
this
move which isn't the first instinct
exactly I can't I can't make it
apparently but but you give up The Rook
for the Knight and then you hold the
opposite color Bishop but that's also
probably going to be a little bit of a
struggle no Black's the one who's still
calling the shots with the attack
against White's King I'm actually
somewhat surprised it's this equal this
position like how is that equal yeah it
looks to me like it should be made but
apparently it isn't yeah I don't know
what's happening here why isn't it
making M okay just click on H2 yes and
now G3 no H2
yes yeah
okay yeah why isn't Queen G5 winning
here I'm very conf H3 I guess yeah did
you lose F3 as well right what I'll go
Queen H5 and queen F3 you're or you
don't care no I do
care I care more about Peter's handling
no this is going to be this is going to
be a whole whole sub for the next Mee
for the next uh week and a half yeah
yeah I think it's just white just
unconvinced and unwilling to play this
position that's what's happening right
now well it's the machine trying to tell
Peter like come on you don't want to
this is not what we want that's not what
you want let's discuss something more
exciting exciting uh let's do that as we
leave that game and I'm going to go over
to Anish and Wesley so even though we
haven't seen much that game is looks to
be headed to a draw with the Bishops of
opposite color regardless of the fact
that black pardon me white has an extra
Pawn on
G6 perfectly perfectly safe that was
also a kind of a revelation for me was
uh again these Bishops of opposite color
positions where the bishop could hold
two connected pass pawns comfortably
like it's not even close no like wow
that was really shocking it's it's so so
easy this is a single Pawn yes which
should be much easier there you need to
know a few places to uh to be able to
keep your bishop and King at the right
spot but here that's not even a question
and these positions are so complicated
and a lot of us think that if it's
opposite color Bishop it should just end
in a draw but very often if you've got
more pieces on the board and that's what
it comes to is peace activity like the
position that we saw in yanan's game if
it's about attack opposite color Bishops
can be so dangerous because it doesn't
have a challenger exactly with the
queens or other pieces on the board not
so case this is not it uh I'm going to
go to the game of Ray Robson because I
think that Sam is beginning to take over
after Queen F4 King H1 that's a very
crafty little move by Sam is he's
setting up ideas of Bishop D2 he's also
excuse me that could be a half open G
file that's very useful and look at what
he's done I think he's made some
marvelous progress here um now having
said that uh without the ability to play
Knight
G4 what have I accomplished and what's
next because black wants to come in with
Rook to E2 of course I I I need to play
for uh Rook to
H3 and I think that's an important point
because now if you go Rook E2 you're
just in time getting the move that you
want Rook
E2 should I be playing Queen H3 or
should I be playing Rook H3 Queen
G6 and Knight G4 see oh excuse me Queen
e for check came out of nowhere well we
do have Rook D3 on the board they may be
following what about Rook H3 Rook H3 all
right and as uh we Analyze This we're
going to interrupt ourselves to jump to
Studio with Anastasia and a special
guest take it away
Anastasia thank you yaser and here I'm
really with a special guest ala fua is
here with us welcome ala ala is the
winner of the previous St Louis rapid in
bit event EV how do you feel yourself
here today we have changed the playing
venue and we play today in the Hall of
Fame how did it go yeah the set up the
feeling of the playing Hall is the same
I feel like he changed the playe hall
but uh the feeling of the chess board
and everything is same so it's not big
change but yeah and I feel happy with my
play I think it was a decent day I could
have maybe pushed last game more but
other than that it was a good day I
think especially I had two blacks yeah
yeah you started with two black pieces
and your Victory against Fab I think it
was really amazing I mean this um
opposite castling yes position maybe you
can show a little bit what was happening
there it's very typical that after H3
white cannot Castle short so it's very
safe to Castle long and um so you felt
that your attack will be faster right
yeah and probably here he has to just go
for equal position with KN C4 takes
takes and Bishop C5 and is very equal
but he want he was ambitious here mhm
and decided to go for this for this
position and but I'm always faster
because I have two Bishops and Knight H5
knight4 is really quick he has to push
here but it takes a lot of time so you
like your position here yeah yeah I knew
the position so it's very typical and it
was it was a very like it was a very
easy game actually because my moves were
very straightforward mhm and he was
taking his time to make some mess like
some complication but it's not easy
because you're getting M yeah you're
just I don't know nothing is happening
on the queen side right it feels like
always you have some AB sacrifice the
bishop but Queen is always so yeah I
mean B6 could look weak but it's not
yeah so here he has has to give up his
second bishop and then yeah this is I'm
attacking for free I'm not even
sacrificing anything so um yeah it's
slowly slowly here just it was
very easy game could you expect it
expect it you know in the first round
against Fabby to win with black pieces
like that I beat Fabby in this Berlin
line three four times actually with
black yeah candidates also I don't know
why he goes against always this against
me but but he feels like he's always has
CH but we have some questions to Fab to
ask later yes but yeah I mean it went
smoothly for you the the second game
finished in a draw right against Jeffrey
Jun and um there was some repetition you
had black pieces and then okay the last
round you play against your compatriot
Maxim V graph and um with white pieces
finally what do you think you you had
you had some oh you decided to avoid
open C right yeah yeah I mean Maxine is
very well prepared so and I have a good
score in the tournament so I didn't need
to
uh RIS so much yeah so I decided to
choose a very solid line but um this is
a very old Theory and I couldn't
remember what was the what were the
details but I think yes maybe it was
perfect game or but yeah it seemed like
actually a computer is happy with both
of you but let's say was there any
moment in this game you felt that you
could have something um I felt like but
this is Theory probably stupid to say I
felt like here I have good chance but I
felt here we could try some other moves
but the pieces got exchanged yeah and at
the end it was just actually I mean so
many trades followed up yeah ala such a
great start for you I mean do you feel
really good I mean to be here to come
back yeah it feels really great the
everything is perfect the playing Hall
they really managed to make it
professional so um until here I'm very
happy but we'll see how it'll go yeah
exactly all the best of Lu for you and
we're are going back to the studio thank
you Anastasia thank you uh Ali Raza as
again he comes back to St Louis this has
got to be his favorite City uh what
happened last year winning the blitz
winning the singfield cup winning the
grandchester I mean it was just a
magical magical moment what's going on
uh between Sam and Ray Robson I keep
flip-flopping in my mind I at first I
thought Sam might have been doing
something but no no Ray is taking over
here as you can see uh the line we were
discussing uh came on the board and
queen H3 was actually stronger than Rook
H3 H3 was played but it turned out that
the trade of this many pieces actually
favors black quite a bit I think maybe
uh didn't realize he will not be able to
take on H6 here because after King G6
followed by Rook h he just loses that
piece and oops Knight had to go to E5
and also this very precise move C6 C5
seems like we're opening up opening up
this bishop on C3 for some discovered
check activities hanging yeah but the
fact that Bishop takes C5 check is a
check changes the relation quite a bit
here so what we have on the board here
is uh is this position where four Ps
very nice blockade on the D3 Square
finally a very nice Square for this
Knight potentially some passer on the
queen side if white gets there but four
pawns running on the king side is a much
more
immediate issue to address uh when you
see the move F5 F4 and Rook E3 and then
you see five connected Fast Point you
start to think wait a minute something's
gone wrong something's gone wrong
something's gone wrong and it was about
these pawns right that you got these
extra pawns but they weren't moving but
now they're they've got the mobility
they're there the gon if that find
itself G4 F3 coming in you go King F5
you go G4 and it looks like it could be
very very dangerous maybe just simply
losing Rook E6 King F5 and a score H5 H4
KING5 just just continue uh going going
in yeah and he hit the D5 Pawn okay I
think also maybe he wants to play Rook
B3 I think it's more even about counter
play creating some work for this Rook on
H3 because it was very much
wholeheartedly agreed yeah this is still
very sharp it could like if black spends
too much time trying not to lose
anything EAS spoil it yeah I think you
have to play very energetically as as
you can see here on our screen the main
line of the machine now is just giving
up on D5 and
then yeah will I or will I not be able
to make the move Bishop B8 is a big
question here and the answer is who
knows uh and then it also gives up the
PA come
on let me make a move
no move
no now instantly maybe it was played no
it was not played no uh and then it
gives up on B7 as well just to continue
pushing uh pushing on the king side so
the right way to approach this for uh
for Ray would be to go completely all in
on making as much progress on the king
side as possible you don't and he played
Rook e five instead which is what I mean
it's very easy to decide I don't I don't
have to I don't have to rush things I
don't have to give up any of my
you know he'll got gains I want to
preserve everything it's not as fast is
such a human move you just defend the D5
Pawn but not until you see Rook B3 and
Knight to D3 that or also A5 A6 actually
tactically there there might be an idea
here of playing A5 then playing A6 and
trying to get this Fork on C6 going so
this is nice there might also be
tactical issues with uh with what we're
doing here okay that's a surprise idea
on the board has he played A5 did he
find this Rook e five a I'm very
confused because it says he played Rook
e seven and I don't really like why
would you he actually did play Rook E7
played Rook E5 A5 Rook E7 and then came
this very nice move A5 with with the
evil intentions of A6 and Knight C6 and
Rook E7 this is very very confusing
because we are now you lose the pawn
with a Tempo with a yeah I'm not sure
what he's intending to do here is
intending to play Rook E5 here or Rook
to D7 I don't know yeah I'm I'm he's
played Rook B3 by the way he said also
also makes perfect sense I think yeah
the other move that actually funnily
crossed my mind was if we wanted to play
A6 maybe The Rook on
A3
yeah this is let's just check in with
Liam yes by the way is coming into this
round tied for first and he's taken over
over completely I mean that's two extra
pawns extremely active Rooks and black
king in a bit of a Kill Zone there oh
definitely this has gone uh South in a
huge way Liam completely winning I would
say after this move Bishop to
D4 resignation wow done deal as Liam on
fire yeah Webster University two and a
half out of three well five out of six
and arguably he should be disappointed
right because he had a completely
winning position in round two that he
didn't win exactly let's jump uh into
studio with Anastasia and a special
guest yeah we have really special guest
we have Anish GE with us I mean Anish
hello welcome to the studio and it's
really nice to see you here again U but
I felt today that it was a day of missed
opportunities for you I every every game
I was checking you had really good
chances let's start from the beginning
let's go through all the games very
quickly I mean it's also
day of Miss opportunities for my
opponent because every round they facing
me which is an opportunity and which
they kept missing so it's all relative I
think but U of course I had some uh good
uh good chances first game of course I
was U completely winning at one point I
mean the opening he fell into my trap uh
just yesterday I realized that H6 is
also very likely here instead of oh this
instead of que Tex E4 which is the main
move where it's sort of equal with
accurate play but after H6 it feel smart
toe yeah there is this rookie one rookie
one move I like so much you know now you
cannot take on G5 yes and it took me
some time to realize it yes yeah but I
knew that I was expecting some Queen A3
I thought it was not so I mean I knew
computer gives like uh rook3 right yeah
no this is just over so I thought
computer gives this like um some big
plus oh well let's go mhm big plus um
but I mean I wasn't sure during the game
like how bad it is I don't know why he
didn't play Queen A3 he played Rook C8
but I could take on E7 also maybe was
better I miss Bishop D1 and here I kind
of um to my surprise here I thought he
completely lost but after Bishop D1 to
my surprise was not so simple the end
game also shouldn't have been so easy if
he had played Bishop of eight here and
actually it might still be within for
him because the thing is that he sort of
has to control my pawns so here the
problem was that I started getting
obsessed about this idea of promoting my
Pawns of course and I can understand why
yeah you really want he miss Bishop
before before the trick is that after
Rook A2 I've got
um
oh I already missed uh Rook A1 here
because I have D6 and E6 E6 I don't have
because to take Rook A1 so I miss this
Rook a one thing everywhere but D6 here
also wins and after A5 okay he desperate
I mean he miss Bishop before now Bishop
f8 there is also
d67 just so he missed this and um here I
mean I just um I just Pro I mean I go D6
I'm going D7 so he'll go B4 and okay of
course I understand this position is
completely winning for me but um I
started to think like um you know it
will maybe take a while to convert I was
thinking maybe he'll put Bishop here I
have to Knight E4 is maybe not so easy I
have to defend this and then he will
attack my Bishop I mean I am completely
winning of course okay it's cannot be
Block it's just it will take some time
so I thought maybe of course I
understand I'm winning and I normally
take this without thinking but suddenly
I thought okay maybe I just can put him
away with E6 and my logic was that he
sure of has to go B4 because I thought
E7 is quinning and I Mr one everywhere
and here um yeah I just thought okay I
have this position versus the one versus
this position and like this is maybe
even more winning I missed Rook A1
everywhere so I thought that he has to I
don't know threatening like so I thought
he might go B two or something then I
think I have Rook E4 that's what I was
thinking and then I will go E7 Rook F4
Rook f8 like I just Queen my Pawn so I
thought okay it's just winning and then
I realiz yes yeah when when I make this
move like with my hand like I sort of
feel like I I see this bishop on G7 like
I open this diagonal feels kind of wrong
you know like the the opponent sort of
opening and then I like yeah but this
kind of long diagonal and Rook a one of
course is I mean Rook a one is
everywhere the problem so I missed this
move like and when he played it it's
over so it was just like one move I mean
I'm just winning with D6 I don't know
exactly that's what I felt also yes that
you were so winning in this game and
round two I mean against neppa this
crazy game as well yeah that one was
always less one-sided because um at one
point okay I um let's check this
critical moment I think I asked him
after the game if he missed this C4 and
he said of course I missed it so let's
let's maybe show this moment there were
many moment I mean okay I were yes I
sort of uh B6 is not from not from this
uh not from this fairy tale from
something something else um so I don't
know B6 is wasted wasted move so now
when I go B5 um he's just in time to
take on C4 and I have this one trick in
the game where Knight G5 BC that now I
have this B2 in the end so this maybe
what he missed from afar like this is
like one trick that I have so the whole
thing works out so we have to move a
little bit faster I mean no I don't
think we have any
rush you could go Queen A3 which is very
nice because if CB he has got CB and
that's quite nice so he also had Miss
some opportunities to be fa C4 C4 yes
this was a critical moment I think after
that you are absolutely winning in this
game yeah I'm winning but not with the
clock that I have I think I had at that
point uh it says 4 minutes I felt like I
had 10 seconds but maybe I had I don't
think I had four minutes but I don't
know I felt like I had no time at all
and um yeah then I played very badly so
what was the last moment where you
missed this like chances for the the
victory yeah you know just generally I'm
just um I'm just you know the moment I
was born already I think is when when
things were getting difficult it was
never so hly like I had like seconds it
was never obvious to me because the
problem is okay I have the extra Pawn
but I have a very bad KN on G6 it's
never EAS long term like so yeah I think
Knight B5 was the move I didn't even
consider that move I mean I considered
bringing the Knight to D4 but I thought
Knight E7 knight6 Knight D4 and um I
didn't even consider Knight B5 and I had
no time and the thing is if white sort
of gets King G2 uh long long term I'm a
little bit um not doing as winning as as
um short term because my knight on G6 is
very very bad so I kind of just um okay
so I mean thank you so much I mean the
day was not so bad
three draws but I wish you all the best
of luck in the next rounds and we are
going back to the studio things are
getting crazy thank you uh Anastasia I
missed at Birth something Anish might
have missed some moves in the game but
he missed none of the jokes in the inter
no he didn't miss a moment there and
we've got this fascinating position you
don't normally see four pass pawns
getting this close to promotion and the
players are on increment as we've just
seen the last trick uh Sam is hoping
that after B takes he's going to play B6
and hoping that his B Pawn will somehow
magically make it after King takes B3 to
could have taken the Knight there and
just G F2 F1 check because he gives the
first check but B takes A6 is uh also
not bad at all of course it's because of
B6 you take he's no he's as well night
A5 sorry yeah it's it's still a position
that is quite tricky to play on 10
seconds because at some point you have
to trust that he will give mate with and
did you see that I think he missed it I
he missed he really did and Ray is
played
oh yeah now you you probably have to go
in with a to uh but yeah but it's just a
queen though right it should just be
winning Rook C5 check King B4 Rook C1
Rook G1 should be enough yes that should
be enough
yes still gets there it became slightly
trickier than it needed to be because he
was 15E moves ago he was I think more
winning that he than he is here
but still should still carry the day
yeah if you go A7 you take the rook and
you Queen with a check yeah you can also
you can also go F1 check win only the
rook and then go rook f8 and not allow
the even more clean yeah I'm not sure
which one is cleaner both both seem
perfectly perfectly winning to me Knight
C six check on the board choose a square
any Square B5 I guess yeah why not so D4
you just pick up Knight D4 check you
just pick up the pawn on A6 yeah you're
even happier then because you don't even
have to worry about you have to play A7
here in gamble but it's not much of a
gamble he doesn't even do that that is
resigns and with that a big win for Ray
Robson it really was a topsy tury Affair
I think for Sam he came in a tight for
first and he kind of felt that uh he had
some chances in this game against Ry and
he'll be disappointed and for Ry uh
great sense of relief uh after the first
two rounds uh Ray uh and we're going to
shoot back to Studio with Anastasia and
guest and we have leang Liam here with
us Liam hello and welcome to the studio
it's really nice to see you here and
it's um third time that you
participating in St Louis rabbit and
Blitz how did it feel to play today in
the Hall of Fame yeah it's always a
pleasure to be here playing in this
strong tournament and I think today I
couldn't ask for a better start
absolutely two and a half out of three
and it could have been even better if
you would win this in the second round
right so but let's let's check the game
one uh where you played against weson I
think there was really interesting
moment around this this time can you
please check what when I play uh this
Knight E4 I thought he would just take
on e4 and Bishop E4 Queen D6 and he very
dsh um I can wait I can play Rook C1 and
nothing much is happening here I think
it should be a draw and then he got a
bit ambitious I guess and he played this
move um Queen G6 and then I have this
Knight C5 so now after Bishop F5 he
already a little bit tricky because
after 9 D7 he told me he missed this
move I I think so 9 D7 is easy to miss
right yeah yeah uh the thing is that
black wants to play F6 but this move is
uh is a little bit uh tricky let's say I
go here and then I potentially have D6
as well
so and he was a little bit low on time
so he couldn't evaluate it so I think he
from this moment he um didn't find the
best move and then I I managed to win
this um after D6 I think it's already
winning uh I had Knight F6 here as well
but I thought Queen first is more
accurate because I'm threatening Knight
E5 on Knight F6 now so uh he I think
it's already lost when did you see this
idea Knight F6 let's show it it's such a
brilliant Mo move that I mean I'm ready
to show it again I mean Knight F6 here
yes at the end like yeah so I I had this
idea the entire time when I play after
D6 I already saw that I have ideas like
moving the night and then D7 the
two Rooks uh but here really works best
because if I if I play Knight F6 here
mhm what is the difference uh the
difference is that black still the E5
Pawn is is easier to defend on E5 so it
should be still winning for white but it
may take a little bit more time and the
difference in the game is that the pawn
on e4 is so much is much weaker and
after I I go here D7 um I don't think
there's a defense for black for example
black might play F5 but okay I can go
like Rook D5 uh Knight E7 let's say Rook
E5 and then then um potentially I go G4
later it's really nice that both Rooks
keep hanging I don't have to take them
need even to take them immediately this
is really cool um so let's go to check
the the other games let's go for the one
you won I mean the third round right so
um let's have a look we just finished
right now against jeffre J let's go to
some critical
moments um I think I misplay the uh
opening of the middle game a little bit
around here I thought I had um very
decent position I think I'm supposed to
take on C6 like this and go Knight E5
and then Rook H3 ideas Queen G4 Queen H5
and white should have a small pressure
but um the way it happened in the game
it was just equal I I thought U at this
point he was repeating the move and I
could have taken a draw but I thought
okay let's let's play a little bit and
see what happens yeah that was an
interesting moment our commentator were
discussing I mean did you want just to
repeat the position once or you were
really thinking to to make a draw well
usually um you know in in this moments
it doesn't hurt to repeat once and get
some time and see what your opponent's
attention so you have this habit yes of
repeating um yeah yeah I think it's a
good habit also it's kind of you know
shows who is in charge of this position
because I'm the only one who is deciding
to play on here of course it wasn't much
um
I think somewhere around here uh yes
this is the critical moment after C4 I
took DC and here he should have just
taken back with BC and then I was
planing P fall and then just he can have
FR C8 and this is
um very Rish is eventually we exchange
on
the yeah but G4 is potentially weak so
the problem is that uh I think he missed
this move after King E2 BC and then I
have Bishop E3 and and this is already a
little bit tricky um I see that the
engine here says black and Horn with
Bishop TT E3 Rook Tes E3 and some move
like King F7 mhm but yeah it's it's
still a pawn um a pawn down for black so
it wasn't so easy and the way I play uh
after Bishop E3 he didn't take and that
was just losing from black so I would
say I was a little bit Lucky in this
game um but uh that kind of compensated
for the second game where I couldn't win
yes yes exactly it was so winning at the
end I mean coming first day two and a
half points um is it important for you
to start well the tournament I think so
I think in the tournaments that I got a
good result usually I start very well um
so definitely that's a good start but
it's only the first day and I will play
um all the other opponents are still
super strong so I don't expect any easy
day yeah exactly thank you so much for
your comments and I think it's time to
go back to the studio if nobody has
questions thank you Anastasia our
congratulations to a very uh deserving
uh first place uh player at Tanya after
three rounds of rapit what a fantastic
day for Liam who was the last minute
replacement for d l so coming into the
tournament and having a Dre start a wild
card into the St Louis rapid and Blitz
finishes the day with two wins and a
draw a total of five points Ali Raa fua
also has reasons to be very pleased with
him play today in second position with
Ray Robson absolutely as we see several
players tied uh at 50% I think Sam will
be a little bit disappointed with 50%
and Fabiano uh most especially uh those
players at the bottom of the table
they're well right what a start Peter
for I'm just kind of catching my breath
there I was really really stunned that
uh this game that Ray turned around I
mean it that was a very very interesting
game and know you rarely see this mass
of Pawns all seemingly promoting at the
same time so very picturesque towards
the end and very nicely nicely fought by
Ray who's had a difficult day I think
but finishing it on such a high will
will stand him in good step but I think
the story of the day clearly is uh uh
Liam who should have been on 100% right
uh as last minute Replacements as as the
Superstition goes you know some who gets
gets on a plane in the last minute
generally does very well in the
tournament so we wish him well and we're
not surprised he's doing well he
actually is like I think a very well
established very strong player just
outside the the absolute Elite right
doing great in shorter time controls so
that's that's his day for sure
absolutely and we're going to leave it
to Anastasia in studio all by herself
this time to give her final thoughts of
a very eventful day one Anastasia closed
the show
yeah I felt a little bit lonely without
you guys but still I had chance to see
the players and the venue so I hope you
feel also jealous about it a little bit
so I had chance to to to speak with the
players and um for example Yan she was
definitely disappointed with with not
only with his result but the way he
plays and I think it's because he didn't
play at all for one month this is what
he said um I mean ala I think is um
getting better and better today he
started with a victory those two draws
still we'll see what will happen after
and of course impressive result by Liam
leang Liam um I remember him from 2013
when he became the world uh bleed
Champion so I'm not surprised that he's
doing well with shorttime controls I
mean things are getting very very
interesting and we'll see what the
second day will bring us absolutely come
back to you thank you Anastasia indeed
and thank you for sharing your day with
us it's always nice to have you in um
studio with us and just tell your
friends where you're hanging out Tanya
Peter to you both thank you for coming
to St Louis and making it so much more
uh enjoyable thank you both it was an
awesome day one and we will see you
tomorrow same time same place as the
action continues in the St Louis rapid
and Blitz see you all tomorrow see you
[Music]
then
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited